the media wants to tell you that there
is no freedom flu that people are just
blindly accepting vaccine mandates but
that's not true we now know that there
is a large portion of the chicago police
department that is not vaccinated and
that are threatening to take leave or
just defy the coveted mandate mayor
laurie lightfoot has now said that the
chicago police fop presidents the union
is attempting to induce an insurrection
i love their choice of words we know why
they're using that word why because they
want to rule by decree meanwhile in
portland antifa's caused a half a
million damage and smashed everything up
san francisco is crime ridden and
walgreens is shutting down more stores
and joe biden is flouting the rules and
choosing not to wear a mask in dc where
they have a mask mandate so please tell
me about your induced insurrections
again we'll get into all this stuff we
have an awesome guest tonight sean
spicer is hanging out how's it going man
that's awesome thanks for having me this
is uh
quite an honor well thanks for coming i
feel the same way all right well it's
it's nice to get outside of the city so
uh i'm assuming everyone knows who you
are but who are you for those that might
not know
uh i was a regular guy that worked in
politics for a long time and then uh
donald trump announced i was gonna be
the white house press secretary and uh
my life changed forever ago yeah so and
then the last few years have been uh
quite different i
did a season on dancing with the stars
and showed that anyone who has no rhythm
and no artistic ability can actually get
a bunch of votes and
and i saw people and media get so mad
about it oh they hated it
that's what made it half the fun dare
you human i know people well first of
all i hate that phrase i mean like
people were like you're humanizing him
like i'm a human you may not like me and
that made me but but this idea of like
talking about humanizing people
uh it's sort of it's it's something that
came into being during the trump
administration where there was like this
assumption that we were aliens and that
we needed to be humanized after we left
like there was some kind of process by
which we went into a machine and came
out the other end yeah dancing helped
make everyone realize that's a guy
that's a person well and he's actually
not you know nuts that right the way
that the cnn and the washington post
wanted you to believe well i think it'll
be interesting because you know one of
the stories we have when i mentioned joe
biden flooding the rules it's jan saki
defending the breaking of the rules and
so it'll be it'll definitely be
interesting to talk to you about you
know her role in the media's role so
we'll get in all that stuff we also got
luke hey uh at least the costumes were
great uh i thought
that was definitely something but uh hey
guys my name is luke askey if we are
change.org and i still remember the
first time that i came back on this show
recently one of the first things that i
said is that you can't comply your way
out of tyranny and then i was like damn
that can make a really good t-shirt so i
made it this is the t-shirt it finally
came in in the mail and you could get
yours exclusively on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com thanks for
having me i'm looking forward to this
very interesting conversation me too man
i'm glad you're here sean i've been
trying to get in the head of saki for a
while so don't go there you can help me
out help me man you don't want to be
there i want to humanize her as well
because i think that job might make
people seem oddly robotic because like
you said you're just kind of a
mouthpiece you're not really saying your
mind you're just doing uh
well you're there to to speak on behalf
of somebody who's not able to do it
themselves for a variety of reasons and
i you know the the issue that i have
isn't necessarily with jen although
there's some things that she said or
done that i i've taken issue with but
it's it's a complicit press corps that
sits there every day and nods their head
and says thank you jen i will now write
this and push it out to everybody
there's no push back um there's no
attempt to talk about the hypocrisy the
double standards that go on in there or
or just drill further down in some of
the policies they take what she says
and and at
gospel it's gospel and they go from
there and i think that's that's a that's
actually bad for democracy for all the
talk about the washington post saying
democracy dies in darkness when trump
came in the reality is democracy dies
when you're not able to question things
when you're not able to ask you know
question authority talk back dissent all
of those things are part of the fabric
of our country and yet the further and
further we go the less and less we allow
dissenting voices uh people to question
authority to to even not even question
authority in a bad sense but just ask i
don't get it explain this or that seems
to be a double standard yep not
permitted we'll definitely we'll dive
into all this stuff
yeah i'm stoked to have um sean tonight
especially with everything jen sake is
talking about and it was occurring to me
earlier today how much science is like
democracy and that you have to be able
to question what is going on otherwise
it's not fully functional this is why
freedom of speech is so valuable so
super stoked to talk to someone who's
actually a spokesman for a president
i want to point out real quick as well
the the photo behind lydia yes joe biden
that uh jessica who uh she does the art
here at tim cast made and it's amazingly
creepy
ian was like i don't want that i don't
want biden behind me you guys want some
beautiful life so i got jessica's other
amazing piece of art
and also this was sent to me in the mail
i just opened up on the cast castle vlog
i don't know if it's gone live yet this
is a piece of sacred geometry we got a
lot of very interesting mail uh you guys
will see yeah all right all right let's
talk news before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member
there's gonna be a members only segment
coming up around 11 or so pm tonight is
when we we publish it and as a member
you get an ad free experience you're
supporting our journalists and helping
make this uh show work so also don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share this show right now
take that url i'll post it wherever you
can if everybody watching shared this
would be bigger than cnn overnight but
now let's get into that uh that news we
got the story from real clear politics
chicago mayor lori lightfoot fop
president is attempting to induce an
insurrection by opposing vaccine mandate
i just love that line she said we
believe that the fraternal order of
police leadership is trying to foment an
illegal work stoppage or strike she said
we are not having that the contract is
clear the police unions are not
authorized to strike what we've seen
from the fraternal order of police
leadership is a lot of misinformation
and frankly flat out lies in order to
induce an insurrection and we're not
having that the law is on our side we
feel very confident about it urging
members of the department to ignore the
chain of command
let me be clear john kenzar has
destroyed his police career destroyed it
he is not fit and he is never going to
go back in any kind of active position i
don't want him to lend to to lead these
young officers astray and have them
destroy their careers like he has
destroyed his i just love the idea of an
executive
issuing an order by decree and then when
someone says i object that's an
insurrection
well that's what we get did you guys see
in seattle the cops have started flying
the gadsden flags yeah i saw that it's
become a thing now and the southwest
airlines as well posting a lot of photos
of the gatson flags inside of the
airplanes there but but this is nothing
new from lori lightfoot i mean i am
seeing a lot of comments uh
talk about uh beetlejuice in the comment
section just for clarification
i think it's important to bring up some
of these facts but this is the same
mayor that we have to understand uh just
a couple of months ago during the middle
of the whole covid crisis when she was
telling everyone to stay home we need to
lock down we need to punish people she
was walking the streets being like go
home right now
she also went out there and defied her
own decrees and went and got a haircut
and then told everyone well i need a
haircut i'm out in the public eye and
it's important for me to flaunt these
rules that i made up that you have to
obey
weekend in chicago
uh you know what i think just just real
quick i think the funny thing is
they wanted to defund the cops
so all these guys are saying hey we're
not going to come to work this is this
should be the easiest solution she
should be in favor of this great we
wanted it to fund you anyway but it's
funny once they say we're not coming to
work now it's you guys are an
insurrection i mean
you can't have it both ways either you
defund them and you don't want them to
show up and you don't like them but
suddenly now it's i care about them and
i can't believe they're not showing up
this is why i refer to the
establishments it's mostly the democrats
in the media as the cult because it
doesn't matter what their position was
it just matters what the whim is today
before it was like the police are bad
okay everybody i agree with whatever
you've said for whatever reason defund
the police now all of a sudden the cops
are like we're going to walk and they're
like no no you can't leave that's an
insurrection there's no real principle
behind what they do no it's just fall in
line behind the establishment behind
those in charge but but to elaborate on
the lord life thing that luke mentioned
lori lifewood literally just posted this
yesterday at 5 24 pm it's an image of
her violating chicago's max mask
mandates
so
you know you you ask who's doing the
insurrection the people who are breaking
the laws of this country violating the
constitution trying to rule by decree
not even following their own rules i
don't think the president himself and
and
jill biden were out to dinner this
weekend in georgetown a very expensive
restaurant and they get filled with that
they wonder why people
don't take them seriously take them
seriously but it's over and over again
and what is gen soccer i mean these guys
just go
every time they get caught it's come on
seriously don't you know that's not a
big deal gavin newsom at french laundry
all these politicians one after another
on the democratic side get caught
not obeying the mandates and the
restrictions that they send for
everybody else dc's mayor eleanor hornap
norton same thing goes to a wedding but
it's everybody else should follow this
and then they wonder why people
don't believe and trust in them anymore
it's because of this
and i i just kind of want to add to this
point because when we look at chicago i
think it's fair to argue that it's
already a mess more young people die in
chicago from gang shootings then covet
and and we have to understand the
chicago police chief
union the president of the police
union in chicago is standing up and
saying that almost 3 000 officers are
going to defy
a lot of these mandates one third of the
entire chicago police department if that
happens i i think it's fair to say
there's going to be going to be far
greater implications in chicago than we
could even uh expect to understand
you think about it you've got cops
health care workers teachers airline
pilots the list goes on and on of all
these professions that are saying if you
force me to do something against my will
military members at what point is that
tipping point where society then really
deals with the consequences of this
right you think about all these
professions that we need who are pushing
back i don't think it's about the
vaccines i think it's about purging uh
institutions of authority so the cops
that are putting up the gadsden flags
defying the orders and quitting are the
ones who clearly have an issue with
mandated medical procedures yeah but the
people the cops who remain are going to
be like whatever
this i i agree with you i don't think
this has to do
with getting a vaccine or not at this at
the core of it this has to do with
government telling you to do something
and i and i think this has been bungled
from the beginning every day that dr
fauci's out there is a day
that creates further tension and further
confusion the end of the day if you
like dr fauci you've got vaccinated like
five months ago there's nobody out there
right now that's saying oh wait a second
dr fauci's on the air let me listen to
what he has to say to rachel maddow you
know what it's a good point he said that
rachel if you haven't been vaccinated do
it now get four jabs and two masks
that's that's no one is waiting
for fouchy at this point you you bought
in a long time ago all they're doing now
and and this weekend fauci goes on the
sunday shows and when he gets asked
about criticism of himself he says if
you criticize me
you're like a conspiracy theorist the
same guy by the way just to we're clear
one of the quotes that he gave out this
weekend is that it's probably likely
that jay and jay should have been
a second dose right think about this two
words that don't normally go with
science probably and should it's either
yes or no it's either the data shows or
not but found she's out there going
probably should have been too that
doesn't invoke confidence in the system
when the head guy is saying yeah maybe i
don't know yeah now fauci fauci didn't
just call people conspiracy theorists
that didn't like him they said that
these people are denying reality and he
said quote sometimes the truth becomes
inconvenient for some people so they
react against me
that's just is what it is i mean that's
a delusional kind of thinking we're
talking about megalomania here with
someone who loves to see his own face on
the national television and and this is
a sycophantic individual that should
never be taken seriously in my opinion i
think it's uh let me see if i can try
and find this
oh yeah where he's in his study with his
picture of himself and the candle he has
a candle of himself
yes in his backpack i might do something
like that sounds exciting
exactly exactly do you want ian running
national health policy
we got to get the a nice sketch of tim
behind there we go yeah
there we go a candle of tim looking so
here here's the photo snap it's from the
doctor
oh my god in his work at workplaces
office with a portrait of himself but i
would do it as a joke
to be fair we do have a big tim cast on
the wall but someone sent us that
artwork from from but it's not just that
he has pillows he has candles of himself
he literally has to go on the mainstream
media that loves and adores him he never
goes on the media that questions he
never goes on the media that dares to
ask him a legitimate hard question he
never dares to go after opposition
voices and if he was really
caring about people's health he would
address the hard questions we literally
at one point on my show on newsmax had
him had a had a fouchy watch and we
asked him for something like
70-something days and we finally gave up
because it got silly but at the end of
the day he hasn't gone on anything
alternative if the if the theory which
the data does not actually support is
that
conservatives and trump supporters etc
are the ones that are the big hesitant
folks about this then why wouldn't you
go to where they are and have a
conversation and say okay i'll take some
questions but that's a the data doesn't
suggest that number one number two is
because he doesn't want pushback
any time someone questions anything he
gets so red watch rand paul question him
the next time i think i think sanjay
gupta is a good example of why he won't
right because joe rogan didn't let that
slide biden wouldn't either he like hid
in his basement during the uh election
cycle last time he just didn't want to
get the truth the truth is not the
friends of these people right so so to
bring it back to chicago we also have i
think the nypd the
fire department in new york cpd we've
got nurses doctors
i'm not going to say that it's the
majority i think in chicago it's a
substantial amount because i think they
said something like 59 of cops are
vaccinated so you've got
41 percent that aren't which means
that's seriously bad for a city like
chicago which has very serious gun
problems but there's a large portion
there was i think in new york it was
between 11 and 6 of the police were like
outright refusing that may seem like a
small percentage but in a city that big
that could mean crippling an entire
neighborhood or borough or or the the
highways who knows
so you you have these people outright
defying
the the these uh these mandates
i kind of feel like
i don't want to be pessimistic but i
don't know if it will be enough i feel
like a lot of these cops are going to
are using this to negotiate their
contracts
ultimately it's not going to be enough
to actually put a dent in this and then
not to be pessimistic but what in two
three years we have social credit system
but the problem is you can't replace the
cops right so if six percent of the cops
call it just five five for arguments
they say we're walking off the job
because of this maxine mandate that's a
to your point in a place like new york
or chicago a big city that's a that's
several neighborhoods that suddenly
don't have police covering them there's
not a crop behind them especially in the
whole diff on the police movement of
officers that are waiting to take these
jobs we have demonized police officers
to such a degree that they're having
tough time recruiting these individuals
so you lose that percentage and to your
point about chicago crime goes back up i
mean i mean just a few months ago i mean
who wanted to be a cop no one especially
with the demonization especially with
everything that happened with black
lives matter and i think a lot of these
mandates don't have to do anything about
health i think a lot of them are loyalty
tests and that's why a lot of officers
who are not going along with the
programming not going along with the
conditioning not going along with the
agenda they're being purged and we're
seeing a lot of videos i i played a
couple videos today on my uh channel
specifically of police officers
resigning calling in as they're still in
uniform in their police car there's a
bunch of those videos going around as
well one of them saying some very choice
words for the uh
for the governor
of uh washington uh that are pretty uh
it must be a cold day in hell when you
convince luke rutkowski to actually
stand up for the cops no i'm not who
said i'm standing up for the cops i'm
just calling a spade a spade here and
talking about the facts here that no one
wants to be a police officer the point
like even saying that is still like
telling the truth about what's going on
with these officers yeah i'm not here to
pick sides i'm here to call out the bull
crap there's a lot of bull crap but we
got to be honest with the situation that
we're dealing with you don't have to be
political to say something like these
cops are being demonized and they're
they're they're coming after them in
unjust ways that doesn't mean i'm like a
fan of every single cop or every
department it's just the reality is
like i just said i'm not i'm not
convinced the cops are going to stick
this one out i think they'll negotiate
their contracts and get some special
privileges and then probably like okay
fine whatever but i do think a lot of
the cops will quit because i think this
is a this is a hard line a lot of people
just can't
cross physically i thought about this
like if someone came to you and said you
have to undergo this and you're just
like dude i can't i can't cross that
line i will not be
be forced to do these things
i'm surprised actually that that
with with all that it takes right now i
mean i i'm not in any way advocating
this but i'm just saying that it's funny
that like people walk in all the time
and say you know are you are you
vaccinated or not the people who aren't
actually are taking a stand because if
you wanted to just fake it you can right
i mean let's fake it very easily in a
world like that we live in today it's
not hard to fake something documentation
wise or otherwise but yet the people who
are doing this truly i think
believe it and are and are saying i'm
willing to go down
i think it's a private medical decision
and if people want to talk to their
doctors about what makes for them but
you know can i just not get off on a
tangent but what other
medical thing
could you possibly imagine somebody
walking into a
group of friends or a work environment
saying hey did you get the uh such and
such or are you taking this pill or did
you have this procedure there is no
other thing that could possibly happen
where this would be acceptable
there's actually a great meme where
someone said that they immediately went
to their boss and said if you are taking
responsibility for covid i demand to
know the status of every employee's
medical history including when they've
had the flu if they're pregnant if they
have hiv because certainly we should
take those into consideration in the
workplace if you're concerned about this
the idea basically being as soon as the
employer says
we recognize our liability in this covid
then you could say okay well they right
then every other thing is on the book
and these are not popular policies
people don't want to ask permission and
be granted special paperwork by the same
entity that runs the dmv to go to their
supermarket or their local restaurant
this is a whole level of absurdity and
insanity that people are protesting in
droves including people in dallas there
was a airport employee protest there
today in texas there was massive
protests in italy where police officers
used tear gas water canyons on dock
workers on union workers on protesters
standing against the insane policies
being implemented in italy where they
are pushing the agenda further faster
and quicker than almost anywhere else in
the world right now and these clashes
are not just creating protests and
fights between police officers which are
still obeying the laws
sorry obeying the decrees by by every
exact extent that they are but but this
is also having a huge effect on our
economy on our supply chains on global
trade and and these effects are are
absolutely monstrous and they're going
to be very huge one one thing that i
just we had a poll the other day from
the trafalgar group that we played on
the show that was really interesting if
you listen
to the mainstream media i think you get
the takeaway that luke had which is that
there's this widespread belief that
everyone had but a plurality of
democrats 47 43 so not just barely
almost a majority actually don't support
people losing their jobs if they don't
get the vaccine but if you listen to the
news you would think that this is widely
spread especially among the left and
it's not that's why i call him a cult
because matthew iglesias is a great
tweet he said twitter is people who are
95 percent further left in the average
voter arguing with people who are 75
percent further left the average voter
that they're too far right
you you have my favorite metric because
i feel like it's the easiest to
understand for anyone who's paying
attention is that democrats 54
according to civics believe the economy
is good yeah that's insane moderate 70
of moderates say fairly bad or very bad
88 of republicans say fairly bad or very
bad and the reality is it's very bad
correct objectively but let's do this
let's let's let's take a look at a city
that uh is under the the rule of
policies like this we have the story of
the daily mail san francisco mayor
london breed claims walgreens is only
shutting five stores to cut costs
but pharmacy chains says it spends
nearly 50 times as much on security as
stores in that city compared to anywhere
else all right let's slow down
san francisco has such crime because uh
i mean people are just going into
walgreens shuffling stuff into bags one
guy's on a bike he's running off a
garbage bag full of stuff and so
walgreens says
we're gonna shut down several stores
it's happened with other stores target
reduced hours this is partly due to the
fact that the city basically said
anything 900 or under won't be
prosecuted yep so people are like free
free free run i guess here's the best
part
london breed is claiming walgreens is
only shutting five stores to cut costs
why would walgreens need to cut costs
it's a it's it's a a grocery store and
pharmacy in a major urban center of tens
of millions of people in the entirety of
the bay area so uh
wouldn't what why why why is something
what is happening in san francisco where
they're like we can't afford this
anymore well the cost of security
apparently
security watch they've done it such that
there's these videos where the security
guard has to stand there and watch them
loot the place because the police won't
back them up
so at some point to your point if it's
900 i don't know what cost more than 500
in walgreens right that's probably so
basically what they're saying is you can
loot the entire thing
pretty much
and not face any consequences at some
point it's it's not worth it
think about it like can you name a
product in walgreens that's more than
900 it's probably if they walk out with
more than 900 worth of stuff but what
happens is they come in with 10 of their
friends and they all walk out with 800
worth of stuff
right
there's videos of them walking up to the
makeup rack with bags and just shoveling
them all right and then there's that
that one famous video where the guy's on
a bike in the store just grabbing stuff
and the security guard's just filming
watching they can't do anything right
it's what they voted for if they want it
they have it uh good for them that's
right but also walgreens played by a
different set of rules especially during
the lockdowns walgreens was allowed to
be open so they made they made bank as
small mom-and-pop businesses got
obliterated and destroyed by policies
that prevented them from operating their
businesses and another reason why a lot
of people didn't want to be police
officers is because they got a lot of
hate not just from the left but also
from the right especially when they went
around small businesses and shut all of
them down while all the big
multinational corporations were able to
stay open so walgreens saying that the
need to save costs is bull crap they got
way more than enough money they got way
more than enough play within the federal
government that allowed them to stay
open during lockdown this is not
walgreens saying it they're being
accused by the mayor of san francisco of
cutting costs yeah walgreens is like
they're looting our stores to the point
we can't keep them open right and then
this is this is impacting people on on
many levels as well because a lot of
people can't even get their
prescriptions filled as well
so
i mean just a few years ago i remember
being in san francisco and it was like a
war zone out there so i mean this is
what people want this is what they voted
for uh good on you enjoy it
have fun when i when we had will
chamberlain and i think it was will and
charlie crook right yeah i think so they
uh i basically had a similar approach i
was like well if people vote for this
then let them have it and their response
was that's a very libertarian answer as
it said to me they said they're you know
they were conservatives and they feel
the law should be enforced equally for
all people the libertarians are the ones
who are like well if you vote for it
that's what you get
i thought that was a really really great
point we can't tolerate lawlessness in a
city even if people are they're not
voting for the crime they're voting for
policies that enable it right so the
crime still needs to be stopped well the
problem too though is let's face it if
you voted let's say you vote
you actually do vote because you want
lawlessness
but i don't should i have to bear
the consequences of someone's vote and
that's the problem is it san francisco
until it's a hundred percent you're
basically screwing everybody else who
wants to live there in peace and and uh
you know not have their stuff taken get
punched in the face
it's it's the new normal this is great
that's what happens this is a great
purge i mean think about with the vax
mandates you've got cops who refuse to
enforce or abide by are quitting
law so law enforcement across the board
first responders military saying no to
this stuff officers resigning those who
can
and then you have in cities what's gonna
happen maybe you're a moderate maybe
you're even a democrat and you hear
they're doing vax mandates and like you
said the polls show that most democrats
don't even agree with it they're gonna
leave right they're gonna move to texas
they're going to move to colorado
they're going to leave these heavily
blue areas making them even more heavily
blue exactly 100 i was going to say this
is the exact same problem you see with
the police force when the good officers
leave because they're like i will not
enforce something unconstitutional
you're left with police who will do
anything it's exactly the same in cities
if you force people who are moderate and
even remotely conservative out of your
city you're just going to end up with
seriously spiraling crime and like it
sounds great for them doesn't it i'm
imagining
bill de blasio is like how do we get rid
of conservatives and moderates that's
just i know do things that are
unconstitutional and egregiously bad and
the democrats just accept it i guess
they're going to watch cnn we're good
yeah
stupid policy it doesn't equate as
liberalism to me i i don't know what
what these people are these and if it's
just like if it's just like endemically
idiotic and like addictive because like
they see one mayor do it another city on
the internet they're like i'm going to
try it now
they're responding to what tim was
talking about on the twitter example
that these guys think that somehow
that that vocal minority on twitter is a
majority and it's not and that's the
problem is that they think that they are
by by giving in to them that they are
doing the popular thing but they're just
giving into a very very loud minority
you know
i'll be interested to see what happens
in next year in in the midterms because
we had this state seat in iowa flip
republican
there is some speculation for a lot of
reasons the republicans are going to
sweep in the house and maybe even the
senate
but i don't know man i'll i'll believe
it i'll tell you what i i'll take it one
step further
i think that if if republicans just
literally
sat under a table and breathe for the
next whatever 13 months they will win
they need six seats they're going to get
two in texas because of the two new
districts they'll get one in florida and
there's a handful of others that are
easily flippable because they're
redistricting what i'm more interested
in is on january 7th 8th or whatever the
day that that new congress warns in
are the republicans especially in the
house going to put forward an agenda
that lit that is reflective of what the
people and the grassroots really have
asked for no absolutely no but
but that's my point right is that this
is what worries me is that finally
there's an opportunity never have the
lines been so clear this between
watching the difference between trump
and biden and watching the difference
between these mayors that we're all
talking about now if you don't get it
now you're never going to get it right
and so if republicans in the house
don't look at this opportunity and say
we got it
then that
they've blown it primaries i think i
think people got to make sure they're
paying attention to the republican
primaries and making sure establishment
do-nothing republicans
don't win i thought mike revell was
pushing this thing called the national
initiative that it would have given the
american people a fourth branch of
government they would have given us the
opportunity to write laws and pass them
into the senate i think that's a good
idea because these can these congress
people get in there and they get
desensitized and disassociated from what
regular people want and why why would we
not have the ability to pass laws anyway
i think this whole i mean there's
existence this is kind of there is the
referendum
a lot of states have a referendum
process that functions that way
california switzerland has it as well
yeah
it's it's hard to say i i do think
like you mentioned you know the
republicans they're historically due to
win um yes because of the unpopularity
of biden and we look at the historical
trends
but i'm just not convinced because like
you said if you don't get it now you're
never going to get it there are a lot of
people who are never going to get it now
there's a lot of reasons to think that
things might might flip
interestingly in the last election
republicans overperformed it was it was
to the polls it was crazy like miami
going red yeah south texas these all
these areas
i want to believe
first i want to believe that republicans
will take back the house
and i would love to believe but i can't
that they would actually impeach joe
biden for like all the ukraine stuff and
i mean the dude's got literally
everything yeah not the emails that have
come out him meeting with hunter biden's
partners sharing bank accounts
is that every time
the only time that i've actually back if
you think back the only time they've
ever done anything effective is after 94
when there was a contract with america
and they said we're going to do these
things and for 100 days they did it and
then after it was like where do we go
but if they if they don't get it now
then i think that they're going to lose
trust for a really really long time i
don't know how you get it back because
enough of this stuff has happened and i
think that if what what i've started to
do is as i bring people on the show i'll
say are you committed to doing something
if you get back the majority because
they need to be held accountable yes and
that's that's the problem right now is
they're going to get a pass
and i think that we need to start what
does that agenda look like you know the
problem is
if
someone uh i'll start with this
republicans
when when polled have a negative view of
the republican party
democrats when polled have a positive
view of the democratic party
democrats watch cnn and they believe
everything they're told they watch
rachel maddow it is insane the amount of
lies pumped out through those networks
all day every day and people just
believe it even when it contradicts
itself bill i think a good example bill
maher even because he's been doing well
as of you know calling out the insanity
but he was wrong on the covington kids a
week after it happened because when you
just follow the cult media they have no
interest in informing you
now the problem here is
people are just going to blindly follow
mainstream media republicans won't
so if i go to someone on the right and
ask them a legitimate question and
they're honest about it they will get
destroyed in the media because they'll
be twisted and skewed and then you can
get someone you know in the bite
administration to literally break their
own rules like you know biden for
instance and they ignore it completely
so i i've been talking you know i talk
to regular people all the time i mean
just like you know going out going to
the hardware store people who don't know
who i am and just see how things are
going and a lot of them are like i have
no idea what's happening but they know
trump was bad that's all that's all they
know because they hear this stuff you
know from second hand but i told someone
today tim that imagine sitting in your
house
and turning on the television and
someone says it's raining
and to your point you trust it because
well the weatherman is or a person is on
television saying it's raining but then
walking outside and being like wait a
second there's moisture coming down and
i'm getting wet that's what's happening
right now in america is that we look
you turn on the morning shows or cnn
what have you and you are told certain
things
and you go well i'm supposed to believe
them because why would they lie
or mislead us
and yet they're not accurate you look at
what's happening right now with our
economy with afghanistan with all the
stuff that this administration tells us
and yet the mainstream media's
complicity in promoting the agenda and
the policies of this administration
is so corrupt
and it's so it's so undermining to the
professional journalism that is
literally like sitting inside your house
and having someone tell you it's raining
on a sunny i mean it's sunny on a rainy
day have you ever i posted this photo on
instagram i can't pull it up unless i
log in but it shows i think it's like
cbs and fox news during gordon sandlin's
testimony and
they're two tv side by side in the gym
oh yeah i remember on one it says
sandlin confirms quid pro quo on fox
news it says sandlin confirms no quid
pro quo
amazing right how this happens and but
the funny thing is i wrote a post saying
fox is actually correct gordon sandlin
said trump told me there is no quid pro
quo but in his opinion he kind of felt
like there was one opinion is not
confirmation when the exact quote from
the president was don't right but
they'll frame it the way they want i
want to i want to pull this story i
think it's a good opportunity to talk
about genseki we have this from the
independent saki defends bidens against
claims they broke mask mandate on dinner
date zeki battles conservative reporter
over president's mask usage there's so
much here i love
conservative reporter that's that's uh
peter ducey right yeah so what okay did
peter ducey come up and say that he was
pro-life and had a question did he say
uh jen i'm pro-life and i want small
government and lower taxes now my
question is why is he a conservative
reporter but would that not to mention
you would never frame any of those folks
from nbc or new york times as liberal
reporters not even the msnbc but also
who cares
he asked her a simple question about
their policies
why does his background have anything to
do with it it's i mean labels but again
because this goes back to what we were
just talking about because if you if you
demean
the reporter who's asking it then
there's less likely that you'll believe
the answer or the predicate of you know
so
it's it's hard
right wing is bad conservative bad now
the funny thing is as the saying goes
liberals think conservatives are evil
conservatives think liberals are
misguided right i think people who are
moderate libertarian you know what i
think it's easier just to name the cult
the democratic establishment and their
voters are in a cult because everyone
else they disagree with each other a lot
of things luke's fairly libertarian or
very freedom oriented but there are
conservatives who disagree but they
agree on the truth and the facts to a
great deal
but there are a lot of people who
blindly follow behind janseki i think
it's interesting for two reasons the
first well three first is pointing out
saying a conservative reporter i find
kind of funny but then you've got joe
biden violating his own mask rule yep
jenn sackey defending breaking his own
rule and
not a single reporter actually
questioning outside of ducey who is then
ignored or smeared
where are the journalists now i think
it's interesting because you had this
job yes when you had this job you were
not given any free passes in fact i
think it was kind of brutal right the
journalists were just always just coming
at you with very pointed very hard or
even misframed questions
yeah i mean i i
mentioned you guys before we started i
did a there was a profile and jen and a
reporter from new york times called me
and they said well what do you think i
said look the reality is i walked into
the lion's den every day and she walks
into a bunch of kittens and everyone
thought that was ridiculous how could i
say but the reality is i mean just look
at the video when i walked in you had
acosta jumping up and down like a hyena
and and all these people were like
you know i'm gonna but when she walks in
it's like you know a bunch of
well-trained third graders they sit
there with their hands on their lap and
politely raise their hand and then you
have a guy like ducey who literally just
asks a simple question and they go well
that's the right-wing guy was was ducey
there when you were uh he wasn't no did
you he was at fox but john roberts
primarily was there kevin cork was there
uh from fox and then um um
i'm trying to remember um
come to me but there was one other uh
woman who worked and she's now left fox
but are there a lot of the same
reporters that were there when you were
no
not there's some but generally a lot of
them switch over um it's a tough beat so
i think a lot of times when there's a
switch of administration the folks who
are say covering biden on the campaign
trail will kind of tap in if you will to
cover the white house because they know
the candidate or it's their turn and i
think frankly there's a lot of burnout
after you've been living especially
covering donald trump where you have to
be up early and stay up late just to
stay up with the guys like five days a
week oh no it's a seven a week yeah yeah
twenty four seven yeah you can be off
some days but it's like you would do
like seven days in a row of speaking
every day oh i was so the way i worked
for my tenure was on sundays i would try
not to go into the office but i was
still
you know either on my computer or on an
iphone or what have you all day long but
saturdays i was in and you know every
weekday i don't i don't want to blame
jen sackey there was a big you know when
she came in and the circle back stuff
and the memes i think they're funny
circle back i'll circle back come on
dear job
but i'm not going to blame a person
who's hired to be a spokesperson i mean
we get it when when when the deepwater
horizon thing happens in the gulf of
mexico do we expect bp to come out and
be like we are irresponsible and we
cause the major oil spill it's our fault
that's i didn't mean to expect this on
the right well also like look a
prosecutor that walks out and says look
i know my boss just said this but
they're nuts
like you got about eight seconds before
they're like can we take your badge and
get out that's just not how it works
you're you're like a lawyer and i hate
to use the analogy but it's easy to to
make that you don't get up there you
make the best case for the person you
represent that's it plain simple you're
not there to interpret for them i would
say sales rep is a better kind of
description from my own personal opinion
you're selling policies that uh again
you can't really answer for them
i think that's probably more you don't
go you know to be honest with you after
about three weeks the product sucks
so but these are sales people and people
need to understand like the word of the
government is not gospel it's sales it's
trying to convince you of a certain idea
this this is why i went when like i said
when seki came in and conservatives were
coming at her i'm like i i don't care
you know what i really care about is the
journalists who have decided to lay down
their swords they're no longer
adversarial and you can argue but they
ask her tough no they don't ask her
she says i'll circle back and we never
hear anything she's not being challenged
on that the only one who's doing
anything is ducey and his questions
typically are fairly good normal
questions they're respectful but the
media attacks him but by the way just so
we're clear just so we're clear
she chooses not to call on anybody else
that's the token right so peter becomes
the one person that she calls it there's
30 other people we have a white house
correspondent two actually that switch
in and out from newsmax in there they
don't get questions neither do anyone
else that's right leaning she calls on
all the mainstream guys and then throws
the obligatory token question to peter
so that she can say that she sent one
over but nobody else in that briefing
room gets one i took questions from
literally every single person in there
not only that but when i started i
actually did this i killed the tradition
of starting with the ap and working
through the mainstream media backwards i
started in the back of the room and
moved forward wow because to me that was
that was very symbolic of what trump was
all about and so i thought all right how
better to show this than not by calling
on them didn't you guys do that skype
thing we did yeah so i brought in um
reporters that couldn't make it to the
brief room but part of the reason was to
allow issues that weren't coming up it's
it's all these guys are group think so
if cnn asked a question then the
washington post would say you know
following up on that well what i wanted
to know what was going on in cleveland
in providence rhode island and you know
seattle so that you could hear an issue
that was affecting real people in their
communities about some federal land
policy or a school you know an education
policy issue but
all that i ever got was russia russia
russia so i figured you know what i have
a feeling that people out in america
don't necessarily all care about this i
don't you know
whether it's you or saki
i see a white house press secretary like
like i'm saying it's it's they're there
to sell the policy they're there to
speak to to not interpret i guess but
you know to present this but you got to
remember the other thing is jen was at
cnn prior to coming here these are her
colleagues
they're her buddies do you think they're
going to attack her
like
she's going back there well
let's be fair they could have pulled a
homeless guy off the street put him in
there and as right fair enough
but but let's be honest i mean i agree
with you it literally you could put
anyone up there every day and it won't
significantly change i love the biden's
fake question like you know remember
when that journalist came up to ask a
question but they asked something
different he was like i thought you were
going to ask about whatever but pelosi
think about this we showed this in our
show today pelosi stood in front of the
press
and was asked last week about the the
build back better plan and she said you
folks need to do a better job of selling
it yes that was like amazing oh my god
you said the quiet part out loud
you literally chided them for not doing
your job but that's what they think
that's what the left thinks is that the
press is a tool to get out of our
message i mean how else did biden get
elected biden literally hid in the
basement while the media did the
pitching the campaigning for what i've
got you know it's like weakened at
bernie's man right shameless plug i have
two chapters in my new book that just
talk about the what the press doesn't do
right yeah there's radical names radical
nation but i have two chapters in here
that talk about the complicit nature of
the press and it's the thing that people
have to understand is when you look at
the examples
of how biden conducts himself and how
the press doesn't do their job
then you get it how deep do you go on
the rabbit hole of who owns the
companies that run the media that's a
great question i in this book that's not
i i touch on that in my last book but
i'm not i'm not selling that what's that
one called leading america but but
because i think that's a good point but
i but here the point was to look at the
byte administration and recognize the
fact that they weren't getting the and
we talked about this from the you talk
about the mass mandate now him going to
this georgetown restaurant that's how he
started remember the fact that this was
one of the first questions that she got
asked by ducey when he went to the
lincoln memorial he doesn't wear a mask
and she comes back and it's like well
come on same same answer by the way no
big deal before the before the show you
know i'm like oh sean you have a book
what's it called a radical nation joe
biden and kamala harris's dangerous plan
for america and i was like just hold it
up during every segment
[Laughter]
but i mean but it is i mean is it even
their plan or someone deciding all this
stuff behind the scenes well look the
one thing that i'll tell you is
biden during the campaign said i'm going
to be the most progressive president
ever and i frankly think that most
people dismissed him on the right and
the left he does understand this he's
going to have one term and he wants a
legacy that says i did more for the left
than anybody else i want to be
remembered for the guy
who named the first black female vice
president the first openly gay
department head which is what he says
even though rick cornell did serve under
trump but he wants to nuance it to say
department but all of these things that
he wants to do are to cement his legacy
as the latest version of fdr
a bunch of virtues the only issue is
he's just you know not there he's not
he's like 13 i have a different
understanding of it to be honest with
you i i think he's a shallow man i think
special interests are using him to push
through some of the most absurd
ridiculous most craziest policies that
would they would never have the balls to
do if there was a real candidate behind
that presidency that's my two fridays
ago at a press conference he said this
if we pass my 1.2 and 3.5 legislation
pieces of
legislation trillion dollars we will we
will transform the structure and nature
of our economy he knows what he's doing
so but first of all who wanted him to do
that if you know nobody if he knows what
he's doing he's tanking the economy on
purpose especially with his uh vaccine
mandates especially with his
restrictions on trade especially with
the effects that he has had on global
trade in general so i think if he knows
what he's doing he's he's
assertedly making sure that the united
states gets destroyed from the inside
especially with afghanistan policy
especially with all the policies that he
has proposed never help out the average
american let me ask you a question look
at afghanistan objectively no matter who
you are whether you've served a day in
your life or not and say to yourself
did anybody
honestly think that that was a good idea
of saying hey let's get these guys
out first and then worry about everybody
else i mean the entire thing it
literally took a sixth grader to go ah
bad idea yeah right keep your air force
the idea of look at this weekend what we
need to do is tell people to work 24 7
at the ports really you're not no one's
working to begin with and you think the
answer is to tell them to work more
meanwhile there's still crazy carbon
emissions especially passed by
california that prevent many of these
ships many of these trucks from even
operating in the state of california so
there's many layers to this that we
don't even understand yet and there's
still a truck driver shortage yeah so
being like we're opening the ports 24 7
does literally not correct and you have
to be vaccinated to make sure that you
work now but look here's the thing it's
gotta be you told people not to work so
they didn't make things then they
couldn't ship them then they couldn't
unload them then they couldn't stock the
shelves with them and now you go you
know what the answer is just turn it on
24 7. this is i mean
again you had marty walsh the secretary
of labor get asked last sunday night
what the problem was he said i don't
know if you don't know what the problem
is then you shouldn't be the secretary
of labor you have pete butterjudge
literally on sunday calling it a success
a success
let me let me pull up this story we got
from timcast.com transportation
secretary budajej says supply chain
disruptions could continue into 2022. so
we we just found out that apparently he
was like a two-month leave no one knew
while the crisis is happening we're
wondering like how did this happen well
the guy who's supposed to be running
that isn't here for one thing but
actually before the show you brought up
a really good point about this so i have
a chapter in the book called biden inc
and it talks about all the people
that got confirmed and didn't that we
don't know about and when i say that is
frankly i don't think republicans did
their job during the confirmation
process but check this out pete
butterjudge is 38 years old he was the
mayor of south bend indiana that has a
hundred thousand people and do you know
how many buses they have 66 million 66
million 66 buses
there's 66 buses in a city of okay and
that's who he chose to lead the airways
the railways the seaports all of these
things are being run by a guy that's 38
years old that oversaw 66 buses let's be
real buddha judge dropped out through
his support behind biden right game of
kickback but but here's the kicker so
when biden when he was confirmed
right and i talk about this in the book
that the first thing biden says is i'm
excited to have the most qualified guy
no he says i'm excited to have the first
openly gay
cabinet member to lead a department and
they said that because grinnell had been
dni but that's not the point the point
is when grinnell got hired by trump it
was because he was qualified because he
had the experience when bootage got
hired it was because he checked a box
not because he was qualified i feel like
you know i see i see buddha judge and
they make that announcement he's at the
first gay department and i'm like wow
that's that that's really cool like
congratulations to booty judge on his
family and and his love and his and his
children uh so what experience and work
do you have yeah like look the social
stuff aside we can be like that's nice
yeah i mean that's why i think biden
doesn't care about his legacy he has a
guy that's arguing arguing with tucker
carlson
about a male breastfeeding right now
that's the argument what he wants to do
because to him it's more important to
say i checked a box who did i appoint
not what did i get done think about this
real quick kamala harris she got zero
delegates right yeah so he chooses her
she's not again popular person right but
what did he say not that i want the best
qualified vp that can step in and be
president i want to have the first woman
and i'm going to choose someone of color
so he immediately says it's not about
qualifications i the other person that i
really delve into and there's a lot of
them but one of my favorites is dennis
mcdonough he's the head of he's the
secretary of veterans affairs never
served in the military didn't work with
veterans groups and doesn't have
anything to do with health care right
the only other person in the history of
the united states that hasn't been a
veteran that was secretary was david
shulkin who had served in obama trump
kept him he's a doctor he worked in the
va he understands healthcare
specifically veterans healthcare right
va healthcare systems how it's delivered
etc dennis mcdonough had no experience
except he had been obama's chief of
staff that's it but those are the kind
of people that we're putting in place
and we wonder why we are where we are
this is a point that i have made because
we are looking at a social justice
checking the box for demographics
administration you're seeing it play out
this is what's
happening though that this is their
metric yes if you're on the left it's
not what did you get done it's how many
boxes did you check how many firsts how
many things did you can we say that you
did so that you know it's it's how much
critical race theory did you inject into
the system how many of these you know uh
welfare programs did you start but it's
all about being able to to lay a marker
down for the progressive left going
forward it's a cult
that's what happens when you let an
authority run the show all the time i
think that's why this decentralized
united states is so important and why
the private sector is such a big part of
our lifestyle because you can't let some
central organization pick all the pieces
and parts every time if because
eventually you're going to get some
idiot but one of the one of the points
that i touch on in the book is this you
have to understand what i call the why
right there's a chapter in here about dc
and people have to understand this
because this is so fundamental to what
the democrats believe the district of
columbia was created by our framers a 10
square mile district they took apart
from virginia and apart from maryland
and created dc when they no longer
needed the part from virginia they gave
it back i live in that part right now in
virginia that used to be the part of the
district
well
now democrats go around they say we want
the people in dc to have voting rights
oh that sounds so american everybody
should be able to vote great
but my answer is well then give back the
part in d.c to maryland that's no longer
being used because gosh we did that to
virginia we took it from maryland give
back what's no longer needed it's
already a state problem solved but what
do democrats want to do they want to
create a state among these few hundred
thousand people why
why because dc votes 95 to 5 democrat
meaning that you will have two more
democratic senators in perpetuity they
like to talk about how oh these red
states like wyoming
delaware huh come on you want to make
delaware is microscopic right but the
point is is that the democrats have an
overarching goal which is to maintain
political power as long as they can so
that they have a vehicle to push these
power these policies through and once
you understand that that these people
and these policies are all there for
that same collective reason then you get
it and this is like the great reset
using the american democratic party
is this sure but they all get it the
more people that are addicted to
government the more that they enact
policies that ensure that they never out
you
you mentioned you know you know biden
basically hires these people with no
experience like i said you know booty
just probably just uh here's your
kickback thanks for throwing your weight
behind us but i kind of feel like you
know donald trump had some people who
should not have been there under the
assumption that experience i think he
thought john bolton was going to give
him good advice and that was a mistake i
think he thought millie was going to
give him good advice and that was a
mistake so i wonder if trump would have
been better off with a bunch of randoms
that didn't have experience in the long
run well to some degree
we kind of started that way i mean you
think about it trump look if you go back
looking through every other candidate in
history they were either a politician a
general they had a group of people
around them especially in modern times
if you're a governor or senator you've
got advisors and consultants and donors
they can fill spots trump was a
businessman he wasn't a politician so he
comes into office he's like hey i'm
going to grab that guy that guy that guy
some of them fit well some of them
didn't but he had to go through that
churn initially because he didn't have a
whole group of people that were part of
his donors but there were some people
that joe biden has the entirety of the
establishment behind him is the best he
could do right but but the difference is
that
he has the people he's putting him in
the wrong places right so it's not that
pete buddha jesus is a dumb guy or
couldn't do something in the
administration it's that they put him in
a place that he's not qualified dennis
mcdonough is not a bad guy he's a smart
guy from everything i know but he
shouldn't be leading the department of
veterans affairs i mean he could have
been omb or something he's got
government experience
office of management and budget i mean
he was obama's chief of staff he he gets
government he's not a dumb guy but the
point isn't that they're not smart it's
that they're not qualified for the jobs
they're in this is why i think you know
joe biden's in charge you know some
people want to play it out like he's
secretly not running the show kamala's
no i think you've got a bunch of
sycophants who are sitting around being
like sure thing joe unqualified people
and no one wants to challenge him the
dude's out of his mind he probably
mutters and
spurs out gibberish we hear him say it
on tv when he mutters off my favorite
was when he was saying something and
then he went
whatever just like stop deadness tracks
and look with all due respect he's an
old guy he's losing it but i genuinely
believe he's sitting in these cabinet
meetings and he's like uh carmilla can
you uh
the border uh
uh uh
oh
i'm gonna go to i'm gonna go to bed and
then she's like i don't know what i'm
doing what am i doing and then the media
is like where's kamala harris and she's
like i don't know what i'm doing i would
disagree especially when we look at
what's been happening because when you
see the policies and who they directly
affect they affect middle america uh
people in the lower class that are
absolutely being obliterated the
billionaire class they're getting richer
than they ever have been in recorded
human history
there's a chart going around right now i
mean you could always ask who you know
who benefits i always ask that just
because no one's on duty and so the
numbers are looting no no no no i think
the looters are alluding more than they
ever have because of the policies that
they're implementing that directly
benefit them there's a new chart going
around right now that says in the united
states the top one percent now holds
more money and more wealth than all of
the middle class combined uh so so when
we were seeing such a huge transfer of
wealth when we were seeing the american
people just thrown down the toilet being
mandated being restricted being
regulated being taxed more than ever who
do these policies directly benefit a lot
of the multinational corporate
billionaires that of course have
financed him have put him into office
and now they're getting the rewards with
the policies that he puts forward and i
think he's too delusional i don't think
he's there i think they're the ones
saying do this for us because we got you
in there and he's like yes sir whatever
you want here's this deal here's this
package here's this contract here's this
new regulation here's this new tax which
will make you win which will give you
money and screw everyone else over so i
pulled up this chart from business
insider and you can see that for the
first time it appears or not from the
first time but at least in the span of
this chart that the top one percent now
surpassed the middle 60 percent
i don't know if i you know agree on
necessarily what joe biden is doing but
i will say that the establishment elites
as a whole definitely want to create a
class system where the poor working
class never move up eliminate upward
mobility basically just have ultra
elites who are wealthy will always be
wealthy if you if you're rich and you're
born rich stay rich why why why why risk
it now for me that's not a policy about
someone caring about his legacy that's a
policy of a sinking ship the ship's
going down and we're going down with it
very fast look at the way china has been
establishing their policies their
foreign policy their domestic trading
systems their uh belt and road
initiatives it's completely 100 percent
80 uh
you know degrees different than what
we're doing here in the united states
let's let's go back to the the initial
story actually you know aside from
buddha judge being
uh you know unqualified he's telling us
right now the supply chain disruptions
could continue into 2022 so what does
this mean for us as as consumers what
does it mean for the middle class the
working class for people who want to put
a thanksgiving turkey on their table
it's going to cost more i mean if you
can even get it yeah but that's the
point is that so look let's just break
it down if you can get it
it's probably going to cost more but
secondly when you're adding in
additional labor costs i.e saying okay
we're going to have to have workers work
24 hours well they're not working now so
what does that mean you have to pay them
more to show up
to just for the first eight hours then
to get them to work the other two shifts
you have to pay even more you have to
get more truckers so everything is going
to if you can get it costs more money i
don't understand how that's supposed to
help the middle class it's not it's
meant to destroy the middle class this
is a deliberate attack on them and
anyone else who is daring to even look
up and see the exact situation that's
happening right in front of him the u.s
deputy secretary of the treasury wally
eddie yemo i'm saying his name wrong uh
i don't care but he said that that today
the supply chain chaos is being uh
exacerbated this this crisis is
happening because people are not getting
vaccinated and he says as soon as people
get vaccinated all the supply chain
problems will go away that that's lunacy
that's insane thinking exactly and this
is this is this is not just a cult this
is desperate people trying to hang on to
any kind of fear-mongering that they
think will work to convince the american
people to lay down to give up their
rights the global supply chain problems
are big they're exacerbated by
government and they're only going to be
made that much worse even cbs cnbc is
admitting it they wrote an article today
that was titled supply chain chaos is
already hitting global growth and it's
about to get worse if you remember you
were talking about this i was talking
about this for months on end saying hey
there's going to be some major problems
in the u.s economy i said this as soon
as covet happened i was like this is
going to be a larger economic wave
that's going to hit this country that
there's no going back from the wealth is
being redistributed in ways that we have
never seen before
one percent
it's not even just the one percent it's
it's beyond even one percent especially
when we go into the money printers
especially when we go into the
billionaires that are are enriching
themselves more than they ever have been
in history of the world and and and and
i don't think this has anything to do
about legacy i think this is deliberate
i think there's a lot of agendas here
and i think there's all a lot of things
going that we don't even realize so this
is what pete butterjudge said on sunday
quote demand is up because income is up
well let's table that for a second
because the president has successfully
guided this economy out of the teeth of
a terrifying recession
what what are they judging whoever you
do they understand what's first they
judge afghanistan a success now they're
judging the economy i don't know if they
understand what that word means it's
it's it you know what's what's amazing
is that
you know you mentioned with like jen
sackey or even when you were as uh in
the white as the press secretary like
you're there to basically speak on
behalf of someone who can't speak for
themselves and if you're like well there
guys are more and you'll get fired in
two seconds
at a certain point maybe people need to
be a little bit more candid like you
know buddha judge or biden or
commonwealth anybody could just be like
we get it we're going to try our best
instead it's like this is good news
inflation is great i don't know like i
just i took my son to see the lego movie
whenever it came out and i just remember
everything being like everything is okay
this is like they don't think that we
see this when you go to the store and
things cost more or you go to fill up
your car
and it costs more or you don't see
something on a shelf you don't go yes
this is so great what was the bloomberg
article we need more inflation and we
need it now i think that was the
washington post yeah and again who who
does inflation impact the most the
poorest people uh the middle class the
thing that's funny about the supply
chain argument is again i got a d in
economics like just to get this out on
the table so i'm not this is not my
forte but here's what i will tell you
when you tell people not to work
and you pay them not to work
they don't work and therefore you don't
get a product and when you don't get a
product you can't ship the product and
when you don't ship the product you
can't drive the product somewhere and
there's no one to drive it they created
this problem
they created it and now they're trying
to say okay it's no big deal the idea
that they're out there saying hey this
is going to continue into next year is
not something that we should say okay
good to know thanks i'll mark my
calendar huh it's hey this is your
problem fix it i can only conclude they
want it to happen
i mean if you go back to what fauci was
saying about lockdowns oh you know we're
gonna be wearing masks and locking down
for the next year into 2022 or whatever
and then you get the supply chain
disruptions what does joe biden do open
the ports 24 7. hey guy what about the
trucks the trains what about the the
lack of workers what nothing nothing
nothing that's the problem
and again they think we're stupid
well wait i think
i think they know people on this show
are at the very least average i'm not
going to say number 10 like we're the
smartest people in the world but we're
certainly not stupid we get a lot of
things wrong that's normal but there are
a lot of people who are dumb and blindly
following it's more that they're
ignorant not necessarily their
intelligence they might be highly
intelligent but they don't know this
goes back to what we touched on not too
long ago when you have a media that is
complicit and is like okay we'll get
that out right away yeah that that you
guys need to be selling this correct and
and you wake up and you hear things
about how you know it's not it's
actually the boogeyman's fault also
bigfoot has something to do with this
that's what we're being told man i look
at the the history of the us government
and lying to the people about secret uh
operations and the weapons of mass this
and this in the cuban that and like
kennedy tried to speak out against it
and then
i don't i don't
i i can't i can understand classified
information i can understand the
government lying about certain
operations back once certain ones but
exactly if military
then you look at say like the gulf of
tong but i mean it is just you know it's
so blatant what they're doing right now
how it's like you print 28 trillion and
then tell us
that everything's gonna be fine that's
what they did before the great
depression they tried to tell everyone
everything the other day we're talking
we're going up against a potential debt
crisis okay and one of the ideas they
float out there is what if we just make
a coin and call it three trillion
dollars yes that was amazing i'm
literally like i didn't know we could do
that like you just go you know what we
need to do is make a coin in the amount
of money we owe and we'll just say that
we don't know it's a simpsons episode
when when they they have the trillion
dollar bill and then mr burns and homer
steal it
trillion dollar i can't believe it i i'm
not convinced we live in the in reality
maybe that's where they got the idea
yeah i think that that's probably i was
like yeah just i want to throw this out
there i saw the simpsons last night and
one idea we should consider i'm
imagining they're sitting there and like
you know someone they're like what do we
do and there's a guy watching sims on
his phone and then he sees mr burns a
trillion dollar bill and he goes hey hey
can we do that sounds great because we
can do anything we're the government
okay you know what you you picture you
see us like i don't know if everyone
we're at this big long table right and i
imagine something like the treasury
department and they're like you on the
back wall do you have your hand up
go ahead go ahead no no no every idea is
on the table
sir uh last night i'm watching the
simpsons and bart and homer come up with
this idea and the guy's like keep
keep going keep going i like it i like
where you're going with this i mean like
that's literally what seems to be
happening there has to be like you know
he raises his hand and he's like no
idea's off the table and he says well
you know i watched the simpsons
yesterday and then some snooty guy says
excuse me
what are you and then the church
yeah let him speak he's on to something
finish your ideas son and it's like what
if we meant a trillion dollar coin and
he's like by jove it might work and they
also but we're going to need more uh two
troops and the
just to cap it off the guy who said it
was a stupid idea is already like well
whose face will it go on i mean like
i can't believe i remember seeing the
media running that story like we could
mint a trillion dollar coin it's and
it's like
oh my god we don't live in there's
nothing's real it's just the
government's like
we have a trillion dollars debt solved
is it that much crazier what's happening
right now with the government just
literally printing zeros and
just pressing it on a computer but i'm
on money yeah just on a computer just
sending out loans they're doing it
anyway they might as well make a coin
celebrating it i know it's true i mean
you think about
the idea that we're
spending we spent what 5.4 trillion last
year we're now talking about a one point
true and then a 3.5 trillion and nobody
like the idea is well you know what all
right what if we get it down to 2.2 or
something it's like no no this is insane
and we're negotiating with crazy people
uh i hope people uh are paying attention
man look i'm not gonna give anybody any
financial advice
but
you know we're trying to make sure that
whatever it is we think we're gonna need
for the expansion of this company like
recording equipment or stuff we're
getting now
i told this story months ago i'm on
amazon i'm like we need a tablet for you
know for like work for signing forms
when people come here we've signed stuff
and so i go on amazon and i'm like
tablet and i click it and it goes into
my my cart on amazon i don't like using
amazon i try to avoid it when i can but
i digress i forgot about it i didn't buy
it the next day i open up amazon and
says alert price change in your cart it
went up like a couple hundred bucks
because
the economy is in demand
i mean we're
we've got supply chain crunch we've got
economic collapse in a variety of
industries and areas uh there's a
shortage of basically everything in
chips and then i saw the price went up
and i was like wow i should have bought
that yesterday no this is the stuff that
work
it's gonna it's gonna happen people
don't understand it when the ports just
get back to what luke was saying that
who do you think that affects you
have done very well you can afford that
for the guy or or mom or dad who's out
there whose kid needs it for going back
to school or something or they need it
for their small they can't absorb that
cost imagine this
you're working you're making 20 bucks an
hour and you're like i only got to work
one more week to save up for that new
you know whatever i need my guitar you
know i'm going to write songs and i'm
going to get out of this dead end job
and then you like i finally saved up a
couple grand and you go back online and
now it's three grand and you're like
but i saved up
or you get in a car accident and you
can't afford insurance or you get sick
and you go to
you know a hospital that's corrupted and
will rob you blind for even basic
medical procedures and you know what
bothers me is that i think the the
populist right and left can agree on all
of those problems the problem is that i
have with the leftists not the
establishment democrats is that they see
that and go i know
socialism yeah
everyone more of the same government
policies right give the government
absolute authority over the economy and
that'll solve the problem created by the
government the first place and i'm like
okay i'm not here to say a private
sector solution guarantees the proper
outcome i'm saying
if it's broken don't make it bigger yeah
or better off make people buy private
health insurance that's going to solve
everything it's absolutely insane the
problem i have is you know having worked
at a homeless shelter and understanding
at least a certain degree the problem of
homelessness is that when i go down and
i see a homeless person and they're like
i would like to be homeless and i'm like
would you like not to be homeless no i'm
going to stay here would you come with
us for a shower clean clothes no
absolutely not get out of my face and
that's what you experience a lot with
homeless people but the left comes out
and says there are more empty homes than
homeless the only reason the problem
isn't solved is because evil rich people
and i'm like have you met a homeless
person have you ever done any work
trying to help them actually go out and
provide food and shelter opportunities i
tell you this man i have and many of
these people just say f you
not all of them there are some people
who are homeless who are like thank you
so much for the help and that that makes
you feel great but the solution we often
get from populist leftists is this very
naive hey i know if there's an empty
house in a person without a house we'll
put them in the house and then you're
like hey who will pay for the utilities
who will stop the house from falling
down who will repair the gutters who's
going to do the regular lawn maintenance
you can't just do this somewhat these
things have to be built and maintained
so we can recognize the same problems
but how do we actually get people to
stop screaming nazi and actually want to
work on solutions
because
look i i think this is the point that i
was making earlier about the power that
they recognize that the more that they
trap people in government
that's how they that's how they that's
how they exist right the more people
become free from government that make
their own way that live their own lives
that don't aren't dependent on
government the less need you have for
the left and for democrats and that's
the problem is they fundamentally need
you to basically be addicted to
government to continue and that's the
problem well it's also a politician's
passing the bill whether it's obama
whether it's bush whether it's trump
whether it's biden they always write
checks that they can't pay for correct
and we have to understand that this is
not just a liberal problem a democratic
problem i mean when you look at what
bush and trump did as far as spending i
mean you want to pull your hair out
because they exacerbated this problem
and the problem is just continued and
only made worse by the democrats so to
see this kind of right we weren't in a
situation where we had low interest
rates right now i think people would
really appreciate or feel the impacts of
what the spending means to us i mean
because right now the interest on the
debt is at least somewhat manageable the
second interest rates go back up and it
really impacts our ability to not do
things
and i actually worry
my big thing is i i think that china is
staring us in the face i don't think
people appreciate that these guys are
playing the long game their military
build up and everything else
economically they're doing and the
problem is at some point we will not
have the resources to combat them
effectively yeah and they're also
writing blank checks as well with their
belt and road initiative they're buying
up all of africa they're buying up latin
america they're buying up factories
they're buying up resources what are we
doing we're literally giving all of our
money to pfizer we're literally giving
all of our money to lockheed martin and
what are they doing they're getting
they're getting paychecks for screwing
us over in afghanistan for giving us
medicines that go from 80 88 effective
seat to three percent effective c in in
five months and those are the people
getting the government contracts those
are the people getting blank checks with
no infrastructure no resources nothing
to show for it except corruption that
goes both ways democrat and republicans
are responsible for it and i think even
if republicans do it and i agree i agree
with your point sean uh they're not
going to do anything you know what
they're going to be eliminating the most
interesting thing that i thought
happened over the past couple weeks it
didn't get a lot of attention
is
and this this sounds very inside the
beltway so i'll preface it with that the
house republicans kicked the us chamber
off of their coalition calls huh
and they basically said
we don't we don't need you anymore to me
as and i know a lot of people are
sitting there saying okay what's the big
deal or why but they recognize that for
the first time the party is shifting a
little bit to represent the workers not
the leaders it's not about representing
the corporations anymore but the workers
have been there and there's been this
dynamic shift in politics where what the
democrats used to represent union
workers and men and women who were blue
collars and worked with their hands
and now the republican party because
largely donald trump refocused them have
now recognized that's who their
constituency is those are the people
that need to get taken care of and
listen to and are overlooked not the big
corporations who are there to pay lip
service to a lot of this stuff and at
the end of the day take everything they
can from republicans and then support
democrats trump really broke that system
man oh crushed yeah they the republican
was this corporate party the democrats
were supposed to be like for union
working guys and then in 2016 you know
2015 started to change things with
bernie and trump i remember that vox
article saying the democrats had become
the party of the ultra wealthy why well
they were fleeing the republican party
then you ended up with a bunch of
populist nationalist you know
conservatives
more like steve bannon more like trump
and all of a sudden where did the
establishment corporatists go the
lincoln project i love it this this it's
just it's the uniparty has been jammed
into one weird
mesh
and it's just blatantly obvious for
everyone to see
yeah absolutely absolutely there's
there's if you're not paying attention
you'll be fooled by this wwe style
wrestling match in front of you but but
at the end of the day i think the same
special interests the same billionaires
that are getting more money than ever
are the ones buying out the republicans
buying up the democrats and that's why
we're not going to see any difference
when the republicans take back congress
and the senate it's not going to mean
anything because we're not going to see
anything from it listen here's the thing
that i think
for so long i i'm not a supporter of
term limits i believe at the end of the
day you have to be held accountable for
your decisions right what trump showed
us is that leadership does matter when
the
one of the coolest things about working
for him
was that he just wanted it done
it wasn't like hey how many powerpoint
presentations have you guys put together
and how many meetings it was can you do
it will it work will it make things
better full stop get it done and i think
what's happened is people have
recognized that that's now the new
litmus test if you're sitting around
giving a bunch of lip service to why a
problem can't be handled then you're
going to be replaced and i think that if
they don't get it then there'll be
consequences i don't disagree with you
luke that i don't know that how much is
actually going to get done but i think
people are now saying if you don't do it
get out of the way because there's going
to be somebody behind you that will
primary you and get it done i'm already
there i'm actually at the point where
i'm just saying get out of the way let
me build the fetaverse let me build
cryptocurrencies because the
these politicians are it's a joke what
they've done over the last 20 years of
my life and that's that's that's
excellent that's that's a good way to
see it just start doing the work
i want to uh i want to ask you we we
talked about 2022 what about 2024 you
think trump is gonna run do you think
desantis is gonna run
so
today i believe that donald trump is
running for president
i have talked to him a few times he has
not tipped his hand but everything that
he says and how he says it what he cares
about like he's in
could it change absolutely
but i do think if trump runs no one of
significant runs against him there is
it's just i mean and if they want to
they can but he will crush them if you
look at the system iowa new hampshire
nevada south carolina by the time they
get to super tuesday it'll be over but
if he doesn't run
i keep hearing people say he should play
like this elder state that's not trump
he doesn't he's not the elder statesman
that's not the role he wants to play he
wants to be in charge and get things
done or not in and i think he's going to
do it he needs to be the guy who grabs
the other person's microphone and goes
excuse me excuse me no listen as opposed
to the
waiting to be respected right that's
what people like he's not and so there's
not i don't see a a role where he says
hey let me be the behind the scenes guy
that's not who trump is yeah what about
desantis i think if trump doesn't run
there's no question in my mind desantis
is the immediate front-runner he's sort
of the next version of trump
he's he's younger i think he's better
with the media he's better with the
media i think he's handled a lot of
culture cultural issues very very well
uh want to see his policy positions i
think you know one of the things that
really sold me on just being like i'm
gonna vote for trump school choice was
big i really am a big fan of that um
ending the war in afghanistan was big of
course we might have kind of ruined all
that
but i would i would honestly
just right now based off a very
preliminary view i'd prefer desantis
over trump i didn't vote for trump in
2016. i'm not a fan of of the of the
character you know i understand what
people are
but i will say i suppose if it is trump
i'd probably vote for him again well
look i mean here's the reality i mean
just from a political sense if he runs
he's the nominee yeah i mean it's just
maybe i think desantis is going to give
him a fair running because first of all
but i don't think a desantis runs
against him number one number two again
if you look at the early states and
again part of this comes down to how the
game is played in terms of how do you
accumulate the 1500 plus delegates
needed to be the nominee and right now
the system and the grassroots and
everything favors trump so
if he runs he is the nominee i agree and
if he doesn't run i think desantis is
the presumed front-runner there's some
others things happen barack obama you
know wasn't i mean he was a state
senator four years out trump was still
on tv i mean like there's enough the
time that somebody can emerge but i
would say
looking at the field today desantis is
the presumed front-runner if trump
doesn't run who would you prefer
probably trump i'd imagine i i think
look from a selfish standpoint um trump
but i i don't i actually like desantis i
like how he's governed i like how he
pushes back on the media i like how he
look one of the things that i thought
was so great is during covid when he was
getting all the flack at the beginning
for how he's handling it he stuck to his
guns he said this is the right thing to
do and he didn't bow to public pressure
and pulls and i i like that i'm so tired
of watching someone pick their finger in
the air and say hey what's the right
decision i think desantis has core
values uh that i may not agree with
every time but i know he actually
believes him and he means it and he'll
fight for him what if it's trump
desantis well
i can't imagine a scenario where
desantis agrees to be the vp yeah yeah
he's on track to be president right and
he also
two guys that are chief executives like
that don't i mean you don't want to play
second fiddle trump is always going to
be the alpha dog and so he needs
somebody um who plays that role well and
after and 2028 you know desantis sure
well could come in we'll see i mean
that's the end of it but again if you
think about it
every time that you try to game the
system politically speaking
and say okay well in five years i'll be
there it doesn't work i mean you either
run when you think you should run you
don't but uh i just don't see a way that
you could overcome trump's political
advantages in this in the system people
are saying ron paul 2024 in the comment
section and a lot of people are saying
brandon 2024 i think brandon would be a
good running mate
yes trump brandon trump brandon but it's
like literally not a person it's just
the sentiment people are voting for i
agree with that i'll just find that
alone i'll vote for it if people know
the meme
uh well if you don't i think most of the
people who listen to this do get it oh
definitely dude
yeah i i do get a kick out of the fact i
mean that goes back to the point that
we're talking about the media i always
think it's funny when you show you
expose the stuff
the idea that that reporter stood there
and i mean like i was just like it
didn't rhyme it's not like biden rhymes
with brandon i mean like how do you
how do you come up with that but it just
shows you
how complicit these guys are that no
matter what they said they were just
like well they can they're
congratulating you brandon when i when i
went on your show it was actually really
funny because when you played the clip
you hear
beep joe biden beep joe so it's like the
bleeps right and then i was just funny
trying to hear it and you guys are
bleeping it and it was so obvious that
the bleeps are every like second and
this lady's like let's go brandon
it's great it's great i mean again that
goes back to my it's it's it's it's
raining outside and yet
you're being told it's sunny it's like
how do you possibly get let's go brandon
out of f joe biden i mean i i'm sorry i
don't know if there's some kind of latin
etymology etymology you go back in time
you're like well if you decline the verb
do you have
that's the flag you need luke let's go
brandon i already ordered one it's on
its way and i already had a t-shirt and
it's the best seller on the store right
now really yeah let's go brandon shirt
uh but ours is a little bit more
explicit because it says let's go
brandon in big words but it has uh the
alternate definition it has the
alternate definition as its uh
shade yeah as a shadow so uh
i will say you know as a segue off of
this the two things that are fascinating
in politics to me right now just in
terms of someone who's been studying
this for a long time or one when you
look at these trump rallies you got a
guy who's not running for office
on like saturday nights jam packing the
alabama one 35 40 000 people i don't
know what the attendance was in in iowa
um and or georgia but
tens of thousands of people who are
spending their saturday night going out
and seeing a guy that's not running for
office that's number one on the exact
opposite i'm watching these football
games rallies etc where people are
yelling
f joe biden
i mean i've never seen either reaction
in po in in modern history where you've
got a group of people going out to
support a non-candidate in this case
trump because they believe in him and
the movement and and people at like
public events yelling this political
thing political things you know in a
huge stadium and it's not like you know
how sometimes you can hear a faint chant
i mean this is something that's like
overtaking the entire
football stadium i got this image on
instagram
uh i tagged it let's go brandon
and the reason i did is because we all
know what it means we went i went to a
restaurant this past weekend and there
were two signs in the window the first
says dear valued customer due to covet
19 our food suppliers have sharply
increased the price of our food
regrettably we are forced to raise our
prices for the first time in seven years
thank you for your patience and
understanding as we face these difficult
times and the sign next to it says now
hiring the funny thing is they put
coveted 19 in red letters on their sign
and i'm like it should read thanks to
joe biden
and both signs should say thanks to joe
biden these are his policies where in
his presidency it is
buddha judge it is his appointees
this is one of the reasons let's go
let's go brandon is at public sporting
events
i put let's go brandon on this i put on
twitter i got over a thousand retweets
people understand the problems yes maybe
not everybody but enough people are
seeing this and they're recognizing so i
think let's go brandon is the perfect
phrase for these times because it allows
you to convey an idea wrapped in you
know kind of a little a little a little
nice friendly package yeah and it's
clean yeah yes
it's a very dirty phrase let's go
brandon it's like a real it's like a
real life meme uh but but everyone knows
exactly what you're saying and you know
what i called that for
i don't know if i should feel bad but
it's like people who are named karen you
know
and i'm like you wake up one day and
you're like how did i become a bad
person and now you're like this there's
a bunch of dudes named brandon that are
walking around like hey life is good
yeah let's go brandon now sean i i
really i'm dying to ask you a question i
hope that's okay well thanks for coming
by tonight
catch you later now now as you know
press secretaries kind of sell stuff
yeah what was something that the
administration came to you with trying
to sell that you were like oh my god no
is there anything that was like oh crap
do i have to do this
i know there's there's some people
handbags that ivanka knocked yeah yeah
i know there's some people talking about
these handbags to one of your answers
there are some people talking about
inauguration there's some people talking
about the serious strike um about those
comments that you made before well i
mean there were things that we sold i
remember early on um like the travel the
the travel ban i think we we
how we sold that was
horrible i mean in terms of like we
didn't have our act together we didn't
have the full list of countries and the
method so there were things that we
tried to sell
that frankly i just don't think we did
well because we were new and we didn't
have all of our ducks lined up in a row
um
but there wasn't anything that was like
oh my god i can't do this it was more
like if we're gonna do it
we've got to have everything lined up
ready to go and and that happened more
often than not i think one of the things
that i was proud to have started and
then i left is that after we kind of
blew healthcare we i said okay we're
we're now i mean i remember one day
walking into the roosevelt room tom
price secretary of health and human
services at the time i looked at him and
said okay where are the where are the
groups on us like you know they're
getting ready to do all this repeal
obamacare and he's like which groups i'm
like i don't know the ama the doctors
he's like yeah no no one's with us and i
was like okay this is a problem so when
we knew that tax reform is coming up
next in the queue i literally was like
we are having a meeting every day we're
sitting down we're lining up our top
folks and uh and we're gonna you know do
this right yeah but you know out of the
gate look he was it was it was exciting
and different new but you know we
definitely made a fair share because i
could imagine it's definitely not an
easy job and and for me personally i'd
be like okay i got to sell this um and
and it'll be interesting you know to to
understand the kind of psychology of
what happens behind the scenes because i
i feel personally i would be like oh man
i
well first of all this goes back to what
we said a moment ago tim was bringing
this i mean you're a spokesperson so i
mean no one's sitting there saying hey
before you go out do you agree with this
it's this is your job you know it's your
rep your analogy about being a sales rep
it's you don't i mean maybe there's some
products that you don't want to
necessarily that's what i'm kind of
asking for that's not i mean i've had to
say things over the course of all the
people that i've represented they don't
necessarily agree with but that's you
either quit at some point or you suck
here's here's one of the things i was
bringing up earlier i'll mention this
passively one of the famous instances
that you were criticized criticized for
was trump's inauguration i've heard that
the the claims
largest audience ever you can sit here
and say oh yeah there are definitely
things i didn't agree with and try and
give at least a more honest view of what
the job was like and then the media is
going to run sean spicer admits to being
a liar right
they'll they'll they'll never go after
sackey that way no and the fact of the
matter is look i've said this from the
beginning it was a three-day weekend
we wake up after the president takes
this historic
uh
you know
gets inaugurated this historic comeback
campaign and wins and
we wake up and this is what they're
talking about and so we're trying to
cobble together
basically a case that says this is
stupid
who cares you know we how many
like think about what we're doing right
now live streaming a show with tens of
thousands of people right that didn't
exist when obama was president so i was
like okay we've got people that were
live streaming things on twitter and
people that were and so that's the
context they want to include right so my
point was how do i basically make the
case this is a silly argument and a lot
of people did they were excited about
president trump i know from my own
family that there were security issues
getting to the to the mall because of
increased uh issues and routes and all
this stuff so i'm trying to make the
case and everyone's like nope nope nope
nope nope but this is this is a very
important thing people need to
understand in in any election
dc overwhelmingly democrat yeah democrat
wins 90 people walk out their front door
and they're standing there correct rural
areas vote for our president they're not
flying 2000 miles to make it to dc some
did
when it comes to voting for instance you
know and i'll say this password i don't
derail the conversation but with like
mail-in voting why is it so powerful for
democrats because they have one
apartment complex with a thousand voters
in it they can knock on all those doors
in a day a conservative has to go to
rural areas and drive miles between
houses in some instances but also i mean
yeah or they go to a union hall where
everybody's there they fill it out right
now
that doesn't have i mean
it's just not the same and it's it's so
so when i when i saw this i remember
seeing the story and i didn't care about
you know why i'm like oh did he mean
live streaming or something i'm not
going to get into an argument about a
spokesperson's upselling the president
even if it wasn't the case yeah well and
anything with seki i i want to make sure
this is clear because now i'm going to
know the left just being like he's just
showing no i said the same thing of seki
i don't blame seki for not getting asked
by journalists but but i will just say
this just to be clear i don't think we i
think we could have done a better job
and and just so everyone understands the
president i get back from the briefing
room the phone rings the white house
operators like the president's on the
phone and he said some things that
cannot
and i thought okay hey you want me to go
out and
explain to people that this is
ridiculous
that's not what he wanted he was pissed
that's what i wanted that's what i was
really interested in and i do have to
admit the way that they treated you and
the way that they're treating saki night
and day total difference and it's just
it's just absolutely crazy to see uh you
know how
the questions they ask you and the
questions they ask her it's crazy one of
my favorite memes is stop making me
defend a trump there's this comedian who
did a video where he's like in the
workplace and there's two guys saying
something ridiculous about trump and he
hears it and he goes guys that that's
not true trump didn't do that and they
go
what are you far right he's like no no i
just there's something that wasn't true
and so he's like every time he defends
trump like why are you defending trump
and he's like because you're wrong so
there's a cheryl atkinson came on my
show i don't know six months ago or
something she mentioned this this book
that had come out there's a professor at
the university of houston he's a
journalism professor and he makes clear
first thing he says in the book is i
voted for and supported bernie sanders
so by no means do i support donald trump
in any way but he goes through every
single one
of the media narratives that trump is
accused of you know this um good people
on both sides this that what i mean all
those things that trump has supposedly
said there were and he says here's
exactly the transcript of what he says
here's the context in which he said it
so you know there's and and here all the
and it's like this guy literally breaks
down every one of these things and makes
it clear i don't like him but it's what
you're saying to him where they're like
he's like i just want to be clear what
the truth is about what he did say
not what cnn's headline was
right and and it's just amazing i didn't
realize some of this stuff there are
things that trump said that i just
assumed okay i assume that he didn't
really mean that or whatever but then
you go back and you read it and you go
he actually didn't say what the what the
cnns and the washington post of the
world very fine people hoax right it's
it's it's amazing how you can have him
say they should be condemned totally
completely omitted from from the right
any other transcript right right but i
loved the fact of actually stopping and
saying like and and you know not to make
it personal but there were so many of
these things that happened to me
there's one that that became really
famous was like spicer hides in the
bushes there's no bushes to hide in
i mean like i don't mean to be a jar and
so i'm arguing with the washington post
editor the day after that story comes
out right and he goes okay all right
we're gonna say that you were near
bushes
and i'm like i have a picture this is on
everything that happened was on camera
so i i finished a tv hit and i walked
over to where the media was there's a
row of hedges that you have to walk by
like
it's i mean like there's no you know
whatever like and and so the washington
post is like all right we'll change it
to your near bushes
what does that have to do with anything
except for an attempt to try to
undermine and demean the president it's
the game they play i once had a story
written about me that was actually meant
to be favorable and i get a call from a
fact checker i was the new yorker that
did this and it was this crazy story
about me and my buddy hackers and
journalism
and so so the fact checker goes so it
says here in the story that you live in
a closet and i said uh i no i don't live
in a classical school you're denying it
but no no no no
it's like a closet right and i was like
no it's a full bedroom with a window
yeah but like but like you have to go
through someone's apartment like
someone's room to get into it and i said
have you ever lived in new york new york
has something called railroad apartments
have you ever seen those where you have
a living room bedroom bedroom bedroom
they're connected because of the way the
buildings were built and i said this one
isn't technically a railroad when you
walk in the living room there is a room
but there's another room attached to it
separate and goes right right like a
closet
and i went right like a closet and then
they wrote tim pool sleeps in a closet
so annoying but that's it's again how do
we want it they have to they pick a
narrative
my my friend made uh
spaghetti with white sauce took like
alfredo and olive oil with rosemary and
garlic and whipped it up and the
journalist is like so you're eating
sauceless spaghetti noodles and he goes
well i made a white sauce i'm italian
and they're like but like not marinara
like not like a red sauce and he's like
yeah but i made like an
alfredo like a white sauce and like hey
you know what i mean but like not not
tomato sauce and he goes
right no sauce would you just give up at
that point because you know they're
going to justify right suck
right right
and then they ended up writing this
ridiculous story about us but the funny
thing is a guy from gq saw it believed
it and was like i want to do a feature
profile on this and then showed up and
was like none of it was true huh i'm
like yes here's my bedroom with my
window in my bed
it's amazing though but once they write
one thing like that then it justifies
every other reporter from using that as
a fact as if it's gospel right because
well it was written once before
therefore it must be
and that's the problem and you know i i
mentioned this before but there are
literally two chapters in the book that
go through the media and how complicit
they are and what they do to cover up
for this because it's not always what
they write it's what they don't write
man
journalists at least in in this
beautiful idealized world were the
fierce
independent folks challenging the
establishment holding the the powerful
to account when in reality they're
literally just working for those people
to sell products by the way i'm watching
the comments and one of the guys says
fact checkers and i'm like you want to
talk about like if you go to school and
you're in high school and you literally
have no skills the guidance counselor at
one point comes up to you and says like
have you thought about becoming a fact
fact-checker like i think that's what
happens because these folks literally i
i
when i left the white house i had all
these anecdotes and at one point mike
pence
uh had given the speech about how many
people were out of work and let's just
say hypothetically the number's like a
thousand people were out of work and the
washington post gave it four pinocchios
because it didn't lack the it lacked the
context that well a thousand people were
out of work the population had grown
therefore and i'm like
no no all he said was this is how many
people are out of work but they deemed
it 100 false because it lacked the
context and i'm like that's
that's not how people talk
they they uh
that's that's how the game is played my
favorite is when bernie sanders and
trump both gave the exact same stat
something about inner city kids not
having jobs and politifact said bernie
was mostly true and trump was mostly
false because what do either of those
statements mean mostly true mostly false
that the point was the exact same trump
said you know 51 are out of work
but bernie said the same thing they said
trump was lying bernie wasn't well again
you've got to that's how it works
let's go to super chats let's go let's
read some of the audience questions if
you haven't already smash that like
button get your super chats in we'll
read as many as we can but we'll try to
focus on getting some some some good
questions through
uh see what we can get
all right let's see luke jessick says
wanted to comment on your segment on
chappelle if people are offended by that
i recommend the well-known
family-friendly movie blazing saddles
great movie excellent i bought one when
they started banning all those movies i
was like i don't have a copy of this you
know just because
you never know i wasn't allowed to watch
r-rated movies growing up but that was
one my dad said i could watch important
all right this is we got we got a good
question
sorry i don't i don't know
no you're just picking it up uh no i
just read this one uh glenn compton says
for you sean as someone who did the job
who was better sarah huckabee sanders or
kaylee mcinerney
all right normally
i'm gonna go with sarah and i'll tell
you i'm like
she followed me
um i just think it's different and
there's no disrespect to kayleigh
but i also think that the longer that
you had in trump world to watch
what the president liked and didn't like
and what worked you know so that you
could kind of sit back and say okay less
of that more of that um so i think sarah
at that point we were going through
russia it still had the mueller report
it was the the headwinds were a lot
different so
yeah i'm i'm i am impressed with the uh
the prosecutors that worked under trump
i mean yeah you guys i think i did a
pretty good job i look at jen sackey and
i think like she actually does a really
good job in my opinion too because her
job you know running circles around a
press that being said it's like an
amateur boxer who's
in a match that's being thrown is going
to look like they're doing pretty well
versus people who actually know the box
you know what i mean so
she can literally look back right now
and say hey i was press secretary and
all the stories were great right but but
you guys were also dealing with insane
people that couldn't stop talking about
russia like literally they were just
obsessing about it with barely anything
there and then it all came out
here's my favorite anecdote just to make
you understand
so
the the white house press corps when i
was there
you know
you you got a cnn contract not because
you did good reporting but because you
did something outrageous so brian karam
who is the reporter for playboy yes they
have a white house correspondent uh got
a contract on cnn not because he broke
some story or anything because he got
into a huge big tussle with sarah during
a briefing so cnn signed him
i mean literally that's how you got a
contract was to be a jerk that's right
in the briefing room and to jump up and
down and to make yourself like a hyena
and so they reward him with a table a
cable contract that's that tells you
everything you need to know about how
that briefing room works we got a good
super chat considering we were talking
about brandon mcgregor says all this
let's go brandon is giving me an
existential crisis
well i think the cool thing is now he's
got like shirts and banners and yeah you
know that that like you know he can walk
around with stuff that's yeah let's go
there's a canadian uh government memo
going around saying that the term let's
go brandon shouldn't be talked about by
government officials that it's deemed
illegal now
it's gonna be racist by the end of this
week definitely tim miner says tim
please explain to sean the concept of a
michael malus press secretary and how it
will change everything are you familiar
with michael malus i'm not oh we're big
fans he's uh he's great he is one of the
best twitter trolls but he's smart guy i
wrote a book about north korea we've had
him on a couple times he's going to be
back here soon actually
and he would just you know everyone's
really excited that in the event uh i
think i think it would be of dave smith
gets the libertarian uh candidacy and
he's running he'll appoint michael
mallis who is this anarchist
is michael new right does he consider
himself new right i think so because he
wrote that book about it yeah he wrote a
book called the new write and explains
what it means but he would just take the
media to task in a way people have never
seen before
trolling them
playing games mocking them everyone's
very excited about the following is what
you're saying oh definitely i mean we're
huge fans of michael yeah he's gonna be
here soon uh really excited that'd be
fun but yeah yeah it's just
it would be one of the greatest media
smack smackdowns the journalists would
stop showing up yes
we're just very confident and i think
it's because you know for say like you
or sarah or kaley you take the job
seriously you're working you're gonna
answer questions i feel like michael
would be like
yes
the room is mine and dave smith is gonna
be like thank you michael please do more
like it would be very much so the goal
of
exposing the media their manipulations
the cathedral and less about like
speaking but how cool would it be to
stand up there and say you know so and
so i mean i did a story today at the end
of my show where i talked about the fact
that there's this huge controversy i
don't even know that's huge but there's
a controversy about hooters and these
new uniforms they have and you know back
in 1985 cnn's host jake tapper
was the hooter spokesman and made all
these comments and it's like you know
i'd love to be able to stand up there
and be like well did you have that same
view when you were representing
i think that's why kaylee did a great
job she had that big buck oh yeah she's
like boom i think what would have been
better for kaylee is she just stopped
and been like
you really want me to do this
give me three seconds you can either sit
back down say you're sorry
i'm gonna go there tab four
i feel like that's kind of like what
michael would do okay you know he's the
kind of guy who's gonna be like he's
gonna pull up a book and he's gonna read
it
all right dilly bob says there are some
things tim and luke say i agree with but
there are things i don't i know i'm not
a famous internet person but i would
like to talk with them pick their brains
a bit
we have an event this saturday in the
harpers ferry area uh it's mostly sold
out but we are going to be auctioning
off 10 tickets so it's five slots each
slot is two tickets and that means if
you bid and you're in the top five then
you will you know win so we're trying to
set that up right now hopefully we can
get it to work properly and then we're
also going to be auctioning off
look if you watch the cast castle vlog
you'll see all the jokes but i'll keep
it straight for everybody here we're
basically auctioning off like a come
visit the the uh
facility so we're we're setting up like
a bidding system for like cool merch and
events
on the website soon so perhaps there's
an opportunity for
individuals to come and hang out at the
at the space
we're definitely trying to figure out a
way to balance between auctioning and
getting a ticket because i don't like
the idea of like oh if you're rich
enough you can just come hang out this
kind of sucks at the same time if we put
up like
hey one ticket available to come hang
out it would instantly be gone and
people would be like yo like don't even
have a chance to even try to get one so
we're working it out trying to figure
out how we can make it work um we may
actually start doing big live events we
had a conversation a business meeting
today about actually
doing live events around the country
friday nights presumably because that's
when it's easier for me to travel leave
in the middle of the day fly somewhere
do the live event get to stay and leave
you know head back on saturday or sunday
so we're working things out and
hopefully we'll be able to get around
the country and do some events
all right
let's see what we got here
john r says tim you should attach a
small shelf to the wall where sean is
sitting so he or any other guest selling
a book can showcase it and that is a
brilliant idea it's a killer idea i am
so happy to hear this now of course
you're going to do it after i leave
we are yeah how about this is the shelf
like right here you go perfect just sit
on your shoulder yeah you get a
sketching of it that's a good idea
actually that's a really good idea i
love that you see our audience john
this is entrepreneurship this is these
are the kind of feedback that we need
but yeah more importantly if you can go
out and buy it that's that will help you
yeah yeah
there you go
it's radical nation radical nation
jeb fjb reed says if you steal 900 of
merchandise just don't put it in the
bank 600 plus deposit gets you
investigated by the irs
that's that by the way
is not be
that's one of those scary things that
god forbid that ever becomes law yeah i
think we're gonna you're never gonna get
it undone yep and i think that that
scares me i mean just the the
transactions that we make back and forth
these days between individuals my
understanding is what they'll do is
they'll track the in the total income
and total outgoing but not the
individual
so basically what i think why i don't
want to have to worry
like you know what i'm saying you're
like at some point once government's in
it doesn't go bye-bye i mean it gets
worse it's a surveillance bill that will
know everything you're doing what was it
was it dave smith who said there's
nothing more temp nothing more permanent
than a temporary government program it's
a version of an old quote okay yeah well
there you go
i think it was uh tom clancy who said uh
what the government is good at is
collecting taxes taking away your
freedoms and killing people it's not
good
it's not good at much else that's pretty
much we got a good one here um wayne
last uh first name i'm sorry i'm sorry
let me start over
mr kerr first name wayne says it looks
like the biden picture is sniffing lydia
it does let's go brandon that's the
whole point look at that
i love it
joe biden
we originally were like we need a piece
of art to cover the panels like the the
switches and the thermostat and so i was
like let's do a creepy bite and then ian
was like no i was like i don't want joe
biden behind me tim no you you you just
went no no
no
heart stop nope
all right let's see we got not this time
shan jack says there are no blue states
only blue cities in strategically
advantaged districts
interesting
yep and there are even blue areas in red
states too
jason diaz says sean what was the deal
with that brown suit that was awesome
brown suit did you wear a brown suit
i don't know i don't think i have i
don't think i'd barely remember that huh
i barely remember that it was a long is
this like the blue dress thing i i mean
i i think i've had one in the past but i
don't think i ever wore one oh is he
talking about the first day that was
gray if that's what he's talking about
day one was great it wasn't brown it was
great no there is no brown okay
all right not that i'm again i'm not so
we're clear i'm not anti-brown i'm uh i
believe in diversity of suits
inclusion but i do not i don't i'd not
currently own a brown suit nor did i
wear one of those is that the one with
the pinstripes that is with the light
blue background kind of gives it a
brownish chin i can see oh okay yeah and
by the way yeah i'm just gonna let that
go all right unvaccinated soldier says
my name is brandon and i've never felt
so much support from my fellow
countrymen yeah do you think there's
something to it should i pursue a
political position yes i dude yes
like now is the time for all brandons to
try and get into politics because
brandon that's me meme your way
everybody's already made your merch for
you that's right right you can change
your name legally first name let's
middle name go last name brandon lg
brandon yeah i like it
all right d says shawn's time was
understated but highly impactful my
question did he ever get a manicured
question or see trump slash executive
branch counsel with press before a
speech
so say the second part again uh i i
guess the gist of it is were you ever
given like were you ever given a
question in advance oh god
did you did you guys ever work with the
press before speech oh yeah so there
were times so like let's say the
president was doing a a press conference
or whatever we would find out who was
there that day because obviously a lot
of the the networks switch out you know
they have two or three people there and
so we would kind of pulse them and say
hey are you interested and they'll come
to us it works both ways they'll say hey
really like a question today okay what
are you interested in asking and you'd
say oh i want to ask about how he's
doing with with revising nafta i want to
talk to him about you know the wall
whatever it is and so they wouldn't ever
give it to us but we would know the
subject or we would say gosh if you're
we really want to talk about you know
trade with we had one time with the
prime minister canada was there and we
said you know
if there's if you're interested in
asking something about uh the trade and
the tariffs are you know renegotiating
after we'd love to and okay great but
you would never ever know what the
question was going to be and then
imagine too with someone like jim acosta
you knew he was always just throwing
pies
yeah i mean
well just to answer that question that
was never on our list but the president
after the first couple times was like
don't bother like i'm just going to go
with who i want and it was pretty
obvious that he didn't really he was he
could handle with it did you know donald
before he like how did you get the job
so he had been a donor i was at the rnc
for six years and i met him probably
twice three times uh over the court
prior to him announcing the run and then
when he ran
um i uh one of the things that i had
done is oversaw the debate process uh it
was the first time in history that a
party had actually taken an assertive
role in the debate process which is
insane that it never happened but i was
like this is crazy we're having liberal
journalists
decide the questions for grassroots
conservative voters so i took it over
and said this is how it's going to be
run and trump was obviously the front
runner so he started calling me from
time to time saying hey what about this
what's happening here and we developed a
great relationship i had always viewed
the party like i say as the leak like my
job was to make sure the grassroots
voters decided who our nominee was uh
and then whoever that became we worked
as hard as we could and i think there
was a lot of people who
um
a resented my view because they said
well you know this guy can't win or this
person can't win and
my view was that's not my role that's
not the party's role that's the voter's
role and i think trump appreciated that
and so we kind of started to grow closer
and closer because i was one of the guys
that would be willing to go up to trump
tower help with events help craft
messaging and
frankly after he won there wasn't a lot
of people who had been in that position
that had been willing there was actually
a front page style section
uh
story on me in the washington post said
the outsiders insider
and it was just a bunch of people
crapping on me saying i can't believe
you're throwing away your career on this
guy he's never going to win and and i
think trump appreciated the fact that
you know like i said my view was he was
the nominee my job was to work as hard
as i could for him but a lot of people
wouldn't come near him and so when when
he won i think he recognized the fact
that
you know here's a guy who was loyal to
me that worked hard that frankly had
experience and
you know he offered me the job on
december 22nd
all right
connor
choinier how about pronouncing that
right says i have family who watches
msnbc all day
how do i convince them what's happening
and what biden is doing turn the channel
to the newsmax
that they've rebranded
you know that's the crazy thing though
they'll be told that they believe
newsmax is fringe crazy you know it's
but test them tell them turn in i'm on
every night at six tell them to tune
into my show once and say tell me
something that's crazy or i mean i think
every night we have discussions about
what's in the news we have people on it
to analyze it and that's it but we get
branded in a way that's that's frankly
as i said i had a i got a someone asked
me the other day he said what do you
guys think about how you covered the
election i said i'm proud of it
i said well
i said give me an example what tell me i
so we had people on our network that had
dissenting opinions that talked about
the fact that they thought that you know
trump won this i said great
that's our job is to allow people to
come on give their point of view be able
to back it up and
okay
but i think they're so used to people on
msnbc and cnn saying this is it there's
no dissenting opinion believe this suck
it up take it and uh and so i would
argue
tell somebody who's just an msnbc
watcher tune in one night at six o'clock
tell me what you think and if you have a
problem i i'd like to hear what it is i
mean meaning them because i think that's
the problems that msnbc and cnn
basically brainwash people into
believing that anything but them is
blasphemy
all right i saw this super chat i didn't
know if i was going to read it but i'm
going to read it anyway
um because it's it it's actually kind of
sad patrick rose uh is asking me about
somebody but using the uh person's troll
online name i'm use the person's real
name
hey tim have you talked to jamie lately
uh my understanding is that this
individual was a big troll on the
internet a friend of mine committed
suicide
and there's a lot of things i think i
may have talked a little bit about it
before
i have some opinions on it but i
probably don't want to say too much but
this was a
notable hacker trans woman
and uh i think it was a couple years ago
i think just to keep it short and brief
for the person asking uh probably
because i'm in a documentary called
hacker wars and i'm you know i was very
obviously friends with a lot of these
people
i think the the culture war causes a lot
of people very serious distress
especially especially in the lgbtq
community if you take a look at someone
like you know blair white for instance
who's trans woman but conservative trump
supporter you can see the vitriol the
hate i think some people can't handle it
so it's a sad story and i thought i
decided to read it because
i'm real i was really sad to find out
when i did what happened to jamie it's
just it's it's brutal man is really sad
but let's uh let's you know just try and
move on and keep talking about other
stuff i suppose all right
riding with ryan says love the show ian
is the best really need help down on
luck and need help
oh and then posting cash app sorry i'm
not going to read that one
but let's read a little bit more
blue c says tim it is not a driver
shortage
there is a hard labor dock worker load
unload problem drivers cannot do the job
of these dock workers and drive too
really interesting wow
all right marvin carlson says the
trillion dollar coin was floated during
the obama administration
there's actually a web comic where
obama says like let's do it let's let's
make two single trillion dollar coins
and then after they mint them and they
open the case there's one missing and
they're like where did it go and then
joe biden's at a strip club and he's got
the coin and he's like more wings and he
flips the coin and they're like mr vice
president we can't break change
he was like yeah they're like we can't
make change for a trillion dollar coin
he's like they just bring even more
wings or whatever amazing yeah very good
a lot of wings
yup
what
into the fray podcast says fauci needs
to go on rogan
that would be me
i think if if ro i mean that that could
be a massive fundraiser yeah just being
like watch this thing happen but but
there's no way he avoids anything
controversial or any kind of criticism
or critique do you see him when rand
paul was questioning him and he was
always like shaking his face gets so red
yeah he can't stand any dissent
and he loves to have pictures of himself
oh my gosh so weird cringe do you think
like you know how sometimes you see that
that iconic photo like in in a political
sense like a historical sense and
there's this figure looking up at like a
picture of churchill and you know
they're always thinking what would do
you think fauci looks at factory because
what what
yes he definitely does what would i do
how many masks would i wear
maybe i should wear two masks
all right dragon lady says gas here
jumped 14 cents overnight
we make it up we make a pan of wings
that went from 24.99 to 34.99
five count chicken tenders 69 to 7.99
making me hungry that's no it sounds
good that's when we can actually get the
stock in which is completely unreliable
yep inflation is so wonderful yeah we're
kind of out in the middle of nowhere and
gas went up like 20 cents in a week it's
crazy but we talked about this earlier
lucas
this is this is a tax
on middle and low income people this is
why you know when they can't afford
stuff that 20 cents a gallon think about
it you got a 10 gallon keck that's a
couple bucks you do that a couple weeks
if you're driving a couple times a week
it makes a big deal makes a big
difference wages are not going up prices
are going up but it's but don't worry
we're everything the buy demonstration
is doing is is a huge success according
to them yeah yeah yeah as long as you
plug your ears and close your eyes you
can pretend to be happy hey hey cartel
members in the taliban haven't been
happier that's right
target demographic
joe biden's approval rating is through
the roof
among ms-13 and the taliban yep
all right
jimmy king says tim and crew thank you
for all your do all you do have you seen
or looked up what is going on between
the atf and the rare breed firearms and
their frt15 trigger the case is huge for
the second amendment and does not have
much coverage from larger youtube
channels do you know about that luke
i've been hearing a lot about it we
should have pew pew or phoenix on
phoenix arms on to talk about this issue
there's been a lot of interesting
developments uh about 3d printing and
firearms and i would love to delve into
that topic more
it's and and then uh we'll go to the
range that'll be fun that would be great
vlog material now that we have for
damastan we bought about 50 acres we're
going to set up our own range and it'll
be a lot of fun
yeah i th we theoretically could do a
thousand yard range but i don't i don't
think we have enough for it so okay just
not enough but we'll we'll have a range
my heart's broken
all right donna 1804 says the one
percent is an incorrect framing for the
scale of the class problem in the u.s 31
of households make more than a hundred
thousand wokeness is just
a
what is this
shibboleth for uh ossifying the class
structure
professors our knights and ceos are
dukes serfdom is already upon us
that is true
chris paveto says cast castle is
prompted about culture building why not
collect ballots from members and crew
have will come by and explain each
section being proposed and what those
what are those ramifications do you mean
will
this way
it's new voters understanding about
ballots versus results
interesting that's a good idea i like
that
lloyd nay says question for tim orshong
trump runs i will definitely be voting
for him but what's to say the media big
tack soros will not do anything and
everything to stop him i would rather
see desantis run
yeah they will run i mean they will do
that they will do everything and frankly
if it's desantis they'll do the same i i
mean that's what we're up against i feel
like desantis would navigate it better
plus trump's how old is he he's 74
he might be 75 now yeah
he's going to be
i don't but so joe biden 78 yeah i know
but that's not good i gotta be honest i
think i think an 80-year-old trump will
be 10 times as spry as a 77-year-old joe
biden true still up there i try look i i
had to keep up with the guy for a while
it just does i mean he's up early he
stays up late i'm not worried about that
i mean the question is just i i can't
believe that you'd want to walk back
into the frying pan uh but that's a
decision that he's gonna make
yeah he's in the frying pan i mean he's
doing the rallies i i that's different i
mean i think that that there's a sense
of going out there uh being with people
who who are out there to who enjoy you
who want to express their support for
you and as opposed to then waking up the
next day i heard he loves the rallies
he feeds off of him but what i mean is
he's in the frying pan right now they
just haven't turned the heat on yet yeah
fair enough coming out coming in the
public doing his rallies that's very
obvious people expect him to run he
doesn't even have a twitter account
that's the other thing that's crazy
that's helped him i think how was i
thinking
i don't know i do i think so because you
can't criticize i mean
there's times when he probably would
have weighed in something and then all
of the left would have gone berserk and
now yep you can't i i you know i don't
have a lot of you know i criticize him
sometimes but he would be hilarious
right now that's true and the country
needs that i tell you that this
statement
about about hunter and saying you know
i'm thinking about taking up painting
myself i thought that was
so classic
like we need that on twitter yeah you do
all right let's see we got here
grizlab says hey tim ian and luke what's
the best and trustworthy bitcoin wallet
website do you recommend well first let
me just say guys we don't give financial
advice however ian what what is your
favorite bitcoin website
well i usually buy it through coinbase
and then transfer it to a meta mask
wallet
if i do but that's ethereum and i do it
in ethereum
yes well there's like exodus there's um
what's the other one that's pretty good
i forgot the name of um edge edge is
pretty good
uh exodus those are the ones that
are and you can also i also have a nano
what is the nano ledger x which i you
can hold the crypto offline in cold
storage that's the probably the most
secure way to hold it but it's harder to
trade
you tim um my i i like uh just coinbase
and gemini but there's a there's a one
thing i i will always say is that if
you're holding your crypto on an
exchange you don't actually have any
crypto yes
so but but no advice to anybody i'm not
telling you to do anything or buy
anything are you in crypto um i'm pretty
much just still in silver dollars uh
susan b anthony's
heck yeah i mean no i i this is not no
what
one
collection one year ago bitcoin was what
like nine
61 right now oh my god excellent
investment and the funny thing is
it happens every you know few years and
everyone says the exact same thing so i
remember too late yeah back so back in
like 20 2011 i almost bought bitcoin at
70 cents i didn't do it
yeah i would about thousands and my
friend talked me out of it and then as
time goes on it's like five bucks are
you still friends oh i should have yeah
friends actually not really i haven't
talked to him in years but yeah he's a
cool dude i don't you know we just
slowly stopped hanging out but uh then
it's five bucks and i'm like no if only
and it's 20 bucks ah jeez if only then
it's a hundred oh man i can't believe it
and then finally when i was like at a
thousand bucks i'm like okay i'm just
gonna buy some
and now it's at 61. i'm like okay you
know well so
i think the prediction right now is that
um in the next two months it should hit
230.
so
max keiser called this
i don't know if it will happen
maybe it won't but when you look at the
the the trend waves for bitcoin every
four years there are similar waves and
and it has a lot to do with the the code
of bitcoin and how uh the halving occurs
and things like that i don't know
exactly what is supposed to occur now
but considering the crisis and people
are looking for hedges and outs and just
were in it like the trend of bitcoin is
to go in these big waves
a lot of people are speculating bitcoin
will hit 230.
that being said i'm not giving anybody
advice i am not buying any right now
so i'm not going to make it seem like
i'm saying it's going to go up and then
i'm going to go rushing by i'm not so um
i've got you know crypto i'll do like
small increments here and there on a
regular basis you know sometimes but i'm
not going to like unload into crypto
thinking it's going to go up right now
but a lot of people are speculating i
don't know what you guys think it'll
people are predicting like 200 something
by the end of the year it's always going
up that's the thing it goes down i mean
i wouldn't do any short term stuff there
again not financial advice but max
kaiser was telling me when it was still
worth i think about a dollar and i told
him to screw off no i know uh and i
didn't listen to him so i'm not the one
not to give advice i've been thinking
like if uh
think about this if you just said you
know what just to hear where you're
going to buy one
like 200 grand all right well here's
here's what happened though when when
max was telling you know me around the
similar time he's telling luke it wasn't
easy it was complicated it was a lot
harder it was a lot harder to buy and so
i ended up having a small amount because
like people donated to my address and
then i remember being like i can't even
deal with this hey luke you want to buy
it
[Laughter]
[Music]
did you say yes luke luke was like i was
telling tim like you need to get in this
because max told me and i was like i
didn't listen to you
i was telling him he told me i'd regret
it and i was like i don't care dude i
was like dude i don't wanna i felt bad i
was like i don't wanna do this man i'm
like this is gonna go up he's like no no
i'm like i did yeah of course
what i was thinking is that if okay so
bitcoin right now can get you like 30
000 loaves of bread and if the if the
american dollar inflates by a hundred
times then it'll be able to get you i
don't know what three million loaves of
bread no no no bitcoin no not something
like that if the american dollar
inflates the cost of bread skyrockets
you'll still be able to buy the same
amount of bread with the bitcoin it's
just that you'll if you have us a dollar
well
the the um
the cost of bread is not directly
correlated to the inflation of the
dollar
so okay i see what you mean though i see
what you mean it's not a direct
representative somebody to make the
bread so imagine that they start
inflating the the us dollar the the
bitcoin is going to be able to buy you
more and more bread no idea because the
bitcoin is going to be maintaining
gaining value also that's that's not
necessarily true it's a little bit true
what would happen is
if somebody is being paid in us dollars
to make bread and then the dollar
inflates they're going to need more
money to buy the bread themselves what
make what i wonder is is it going to get
to a point where the people that make
the bread are like what's worth more
bread or money a little bread so give me
i want one bitcoin is going to get you
one loaf of bread now let me put it this
way uh in november when
last year when i was like 11 or whatever
and i was like oh okay you know you
should buy some bitcoin bitcoin ended up
going up to like 60k
funny enough wood lumber went up the
same rates
so even if you had even if you bought
the bitcoin you could still buy the same
amount of wood with it if you had us
dollars you couldn't buy wood anymore it
just crossed my mind that maybe at some
point the people that own the resources
are going to dictate the value of the
bitcoin not the us dollar
i think mostly what will happen is
bitcoin will be able to it is going to
go up simply by its deflationary nature
it will become worth more as more people
start using it but it's a very very
complicated issue but how about this if
you haven't already go to timcast.com
subscribe become a member we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up at
about 11 or so p.m as we publish it and
uh you can like this video subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends you can follow the show at tim
cast irl just search for it and you can
follow me personally at timcast on you
know basically every platform sean it's
been a blast thank you guys for having
me you want to shout out your book yeah
so radical nation i go to amazon
newsmax.com
23. uh but i the one thing i love about
this is the first comprehensive look at
the people and the policies in the body
administration if you want to understand
who's running this government and what
they're trying to do it's in there and
the last thing that i love about the
book is that it's not just explain it
the last chapter chapter 20 is actually
a conservative agenda checklist so if
you want to get more involved if you
want to know how to fight back if you
want to know organizations that'll help
pay your legal bills if you get into
trouble for fighting against critical
race theory literally my thought was if
you're going to tell everyone everything
that's wrong you got to tell them what
they can do to make things better
absolutely and that's the thing that i
loved about it is it was like it's not
just going to tell you all the problems
but it's going to tell you how to fight
back how to get your kids involved in
organizations that will put them on the
right track and you know like i said if
you want to run for office if you need
to get read up on some of these economic
issues that are important because here's
the thing every one of these issues we
have the facts on our side and it's as
the holidays come up and you're going to
be sitting there at thanksgiving with
the crazy uncle the crazy aunt who talks
about immigration or critical race
theory and tells you oh it doesn't like
terry mccall if here in virginia it
doesn't exist right there's a whole
section in there chapter 16 about
critical race theories it's origins what
it it tends to do the goals of it you
need to be able to fight back with the
facts the book has it all in there right
on so thank you guys social media
at sean spicer on twitter at sean spicer
on instagram
at sean spicer on youtube
and um apparently ian's making me get
i'm getting my mind right on mines and
storable food and crystals and yeah
we're gonna we're gonna load you up
spirulina before the show that's that's
right
we gotta we got a lot of this spent like
a couple hundred bucks with all the
ideas yeah that's good ordering things
so thank you guys for having me it's a
pleasure to be out here yeah we got way
more stuff to talk about but uh in
today's video on the luke uncensored i
gave some very interesting prepper tips
and if you're interested in that you can
check it out on luke uncensored.com i
have a lot of fun on that platform and i
hope to see some of you there yeah i'm
really glad you guys are here thanks
luke and great shirt by the way i love
it uh sean thanks again for coming man
and jessica thanks for the art it's
beautiful on the back wall amazing and
the guy that sent me this i'm going to
get your name and shout you out because
i love this this crazy art behind me and
i'm ian crossland see you later yeah
this has been a super fun conversation
it's not every day we get to talk to
somebody who worked with the trump
administration uh i'm a little creeped
out by this new painting that jessica
did for us but it is wonderful and i
appreciate it it just looks like joe
biden is sniffing me which is exactly
what i've always wanted you guys are
more than welcome to follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids that's such an
awesome painting
i love it so creepy the landscape the
landscape behind iana is just beautiful
it's like charcoal art or something it's
going to come alive charcoal well um i i
so go to timcast.com be a member i
really want to talk to you about you
know your time in the white house and
other stuff like that so uh for
everybody we'll have a segment up we
record it now but then we just we
published it around 11. so thanks for
hanging out we'll see you all there
you